Sag mal, Kilian, hast du dir eigentlich dein
Hacktoberfest-T-Shirt bereits verdient?
Ja, ich hab's auch an,
aber das ist...
Ach, jetzt ist es...
Piep!
Ich mach den mal ganz kurz auf.
Kleinen Moment.
Da nehm ich die Folge jetzt
alleine auf.
Hi Kilian!
Ist das schon der Einstiegs...
Ich weiß nicht.
Sag mal, Kilian, hast du dir schon dein
Hektobofest-T-Shirt für dieses Jahr verdient?
Aber natürlich. Und du?
Ich wollte eigentlich letztes Wochenende hacken,
aber ich bin nicht dazu gekommen, wenn mir so viele Leute
Pull-Requests aufgemacht haben.
Aber jetzt ist der 1. November.
Ich weiß, ich hab's schon wieder nicht geschafft.
Oh, Hendrik.
Naja, ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Scheiß Open Source.
Man kann ja auch hacken, ohne ein T-Shirt zu bekommen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ist ja trotzdem gut.
Ist ja nicht so, als ob es sich nur im Oktober lohnt.
Natürlich tut es das.
Ja, also vielen Dank an der Stelle an die Leute,
die mir Pull-Requests aufgemacht haben.
Ich habe sie natürlich sehr gerne reviewt.
Aber mir fällt auch ein,
dass ich die noch weiter bearbeiten möchte.
Ja.
Es ist tatsächlich jemand von alleine gekommen und hat gesagt,
hier, guck mal, die Library
in deiner Notification,
in meinem Notify Rust, die
D-Bus Library, ist nicht mehr aktuell.
Die müsstest du mal updaten.
Hat die Breaking Changes?
Die hat ganz schön viele Breaking Changes.
Das mache ich bestimmt irgendwann mal. Und dann fünf Minuten später,
der hat bloß das Ticket aufgemacht, weil er den Pull-Request schon bereit hat.
Hier hast du das Update.
Ja, nice. Das liegt daran, dass
das eine C-Bibliothek
linkt und du
deswegen nicht mehrere unterschiedliche Versionen
von der D-Bus-Rapper
Library als Dependencies haben kannst.
Ich soo. Deswegen hat meine
Bibliothek andere Leute zurückgehalten
mit ihren Updates.
Aber jetzt ist es nicht mehr so. Das ist auch toll.
Ist leider immer noch so, weil ich es noch nicht gemerged habe.
Toll, Hendrik.
Ja, und die andere Geschichte war,
dass mir zwei Leute aus dem ASCII
Pull Requests an den ASCII-Inviruser
gestellt haben. Nice. Es lebt noch.
Es lebt noch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie es so aktiv benutzen noch, aber...
Na jetzt anscheinend, oder?
Sonst gibt es ja keine PRs.
Das Schöne war, eine Änderung habe ich dann diskutiert, da wurde ein neues Feature hinzugefügt,
dass du Einträge aus der Liste über die Eintragsnummer öffnen kannst,
aber nicht indem du ein Flag-N oder sowas angibst, um auf die Nummer zuzugreifen,
sondern indem du den Namen eingibst und wenn zufällig der Name mit N anfängt und dann eine Zahl ist.
Das ist für ein Magic String.
deswegen habe ich dann dran geschrieben,
ja, das ist ganz cool,
aber das ist nicht wirklich gut dokumentierbar.
Mach doch da mal bitte ein Fleck draus
und die Antwort von demjenigen, der das gemacht hat, war,
ich setze bloß die Wünsche des aktuellen
Vorstands auf. Ja, wenn der Vorstand keine Ahnung hat.
Ich habe dann gesagt,
ich spiele hier mal meine
Project Owner Vito-Karte
und wünsche mir das und ein Fleck draus machst.
Der ist ja nicht so, als ob der Vorstand das nicht
nutzen könnte. Das ist ein Flag oder
ein Magic Strip-Design, das ist immerhin schön sauber definiert
und dokumentiert.
wollen wir es hoffen. Ja, ist doch besser so.
Hast du gut gewetot.
Ich habe es zum Schluss trotzdem gemerged.
Ach so.
Ja, es kam dann irgendwie kein Feedback mehr an. Ich wollte nicht zu lange warten lassen.
Dann musst du es jetzt ändern. Brauchst du nur noch rum, bevor es wird nutzen.
Ich habe noch eine Riesenänderung von jemand anders.
Das Wochenende ist noch lang.
Gut, dass es gerade erst angefangen hat.
Genau, wir haben ja jetzt gerade unser...
Wir sind in der Mitte des Wochenendes.
Wir sind mitten am Wochenende.
Zwischen Feiertag, Brückentag, Brückentagende.
Genau, heute ist Brückentag.
Gestern war Feiertag. Hast du gestern was Cooles gemacht?
Nö.
Gestern Abend war Halloween Party im ASCII.
Vorgestern.
Vorgestern?
Du klingst immer noch ein bisschen heiser.
Ja, wir hatten sehr viel Spaß beim Karaoke.
Ich hab da so, diesen einen Titel, der macht mich immer heiser.
Tragedy.
Die Bee Gees.
Aber ich sing das halt so, wie der Sänger das singt.
Das musst du so singen.
Tragedy.
Ich hab da, glaube ich, noch irgendwo ein Handy-Video von dir
aus einem anderen Karaoke-Abend.
Der klingt halt auch so, das muss man so sehen.
Ich glaube, den hänge ich hinten an dem Podcast dran.
Nein, nichts gibt's.
Was ist denn sonst so passiert?
Uns wurde gesagt, wir dürfen nicht mehr über Go reden.
Das ist okay.
Es gibt ja glücklicherweise Webseiten,
die unsere Meinung über Go relativ gut zusammenfassen.
Unsere Meinung, alle Meinungen.
Wir geben das jetzt einfach mal so zu Protokollen,
reden nicht weiter über Go
und verweisen einfach an www.golang.sucks.
Ja, da ist wirkliches Feedback
zusammengefasst.
Das war einfach ein Link auf das eine Repo, oder?
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Das war eine Metaseite.
Achso, da gab es einen Link noch zu diesem
einen tollen Repo, Why Golang is not a good language
oder so, oder?
Ja, das ist einfach unterschiedliche Blogposts
und Einträge. Golang is trash.
Ja, Go is not good.
The Go language is a mess.
Der dritte ist, Go is a poorly designed
language.
Go's Design is a disservice
to intelligent programmers.
You don't like Google's Go
because you are small.
Das klingt aber eher so in die andere Richtung.
Golang sucks und
noch dann ein GitHub-Repo,
das einfach nur heißt,
Go is not good.
Ja, das ist dieser Post,
dieses Repo, das ich meine.
Mit ganz vielen Auflistungen.
Aber vor allem diese Personen,
die das zusammengetragen haben,
die haben da nicht nur eine Liste von Links,
sondern die haben eine Liste mit Links
und dazu alle Argumente,
um was ich sehr schätze, unten ein
Reverse Complaint Index, wo einfach so die Argumente
sind und welche Links darauf referenziert sind.
Sowas sollte es mehr geben. Einfach so Listen und vor allem auch
so andersrum sortiert, dass immer wenn jemand sagt,
hier, Go ist ja gut, weil das und das
kann ich jetzt einfach hier schon reinschauen,
weil Go scheiße ist und
zum Beispiel... Genau, also wir werden uns jetzt...
Ich kenne alles hier von diesem Bullshit-Speature,
dieser Kack-Sprache. Wir werden nicht mehr über Golang in diesem Podcast
ranten, wir werden uns jetzt nur noch
auf diese Webseite vorweisen.
No non-nullable types.
Alter, was...
Neue Sprache und so ein Scheiß.
Lass uns an dieser Stelle dabei belassen.
Golang sucks.
Punkt sucks, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe nur verreferenziert, ich habe keine Meinung geäußert.
Ich hoffe, es hat noch niemand akronomisierbar sucks.
Ich würde es feiern.
Das war so ein Bild von uns.
Und irgendwie ist Pimpus suck.
Das wäre eine coole Adresse
für die akronomisierbare
Fangemeinschaft.
Die akronomisierbare Ultras.
Achso, wir wollten uns auch noch akronomisierbar.gmbh kaufen, oder?
Ja, weißt du, wenn du so einen Namen hast, dann das Problem mit der Vielzahl an Top-Level-Domains ist, dass du die jetzt alle irgendwie kaufen musst.
Ja, die musst du ja nicht alle, du musst nur die Witzigen kaufen.
Oder du machst es halt wie, wie hieß er, der alte NYC-Mayer Bloomberg? War das Bloomberg?
Irgendeiner war das, Michael.
Michael Bloomberg, glaube ich.
der hatte, es ist.nyc,
da gab es eine Folge von John Oliver's Last Week
Tonight mal dazu, der hatte,
da kam.nyc, die Top-Level-Domänen raus
und ich behaupte es mal, Mike Bloomberg
hatte sicherheitshalber mal
ein paar Domains gesichert,
die ihn beleidigen würden,
damit Leute, die ihn nicht registrieren,
aber wenn deine Staffer halt dahergeben,
also er hat es jetzt sicherlich nicht selber reserviert, weil
der ist doch nicht Text ja wieder zu,
eine offene Domain zu kaufen, aber wenn deine Staffer
halt dahergeben und 400
Domains kaufen, die dich persönlich
beleidigen, dann fällt das halt auch auf.
Da waren also
Sachen dabei, wie Mike Bloomberg
is a wiener.nyc
und John Oliver fand das halt so witzig,
dass die halt natürlich
andere Domains, die ihn beleidigen, noch gekauft
haben. Ich behaupte, es ist immer noch Mike
Bloomberg, Mike Bloomberg
kannst du hier rausschneiden, is
wiener.nyc
Safari
sucht auf weather.com, keine Ahnung, was da
passiert ist.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie das andere Wiener-Spelling, nicht
E-I, sondern I-I.
Einer von den beiden hatte er reserviert und das andere haben sie geklärt.
Das eine ist ein Würstchen und das andere ist ein Weiner.
Wiener.
Ich behaupte, beide Schreibweisen gibt es im Englischen als Wiener.
Genau, aber eigentlich heißt es ja Wiener
so wie Person aus Wien.
Also Wiener Würstchen, oder?
Oder mit E-E.
Tatsächlich gibt es nur die I-E-Schreibweise.
Ja, ist offiziell Österreicher offenbar.
Zumindest laut McGoist-Dictionary,
wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht verschaut habe.
Aber trotzdem schreiben das in Mengen-Sprache.
Auch viele mit EI.
Aber so oder so.
Das ist halt dumm.
Nicht aufpassen, wenn man irgendwie Lebensmittel rausbringt,
dass man die nicht verwenden kann,
um irgendwie Leute aus der Stadt, wo die herkommen, zu dissen.
Ich meine, ein Hamburger bezieht sich...
Es ist nicht, ob Wiener so ein neues Ding ist.
Das ist ja keine Neuschöpfung aus dem 21. Jahrhundert.
Du Würstchen.
Ja, aber ich meine, in den USA ist jetzt jemand,
der aus Wien kommt ein Würstchen.
Ach so, du meinst, dass das standardmäßig ist?
I'm a wiener.
Niemand sagt das im Englischen.
I'm from Wien.
Vienna, abgesehen davon.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
From Wien klang irgendwie falsch.
Aber ja.
Wäre ich aus Wien, würde ich es
trotzdem witzig finden, mich als Wiener zu bezeichnen.
Ansonsten, was mir aufgefallen ist,
was wir auch häufiger mal erwähnen könnten,
also wir freuen uns sehr über euer Feedback,
wenn ihr uns in dem Matrix-Channel
schreibt, da sind wir am ehesten zu erreichen
oder bekommen wir am meisten Feedback, auf Twitter nicht mehr so
sehr direkt, aber wir erwähnen es auch nie
wirklich. Ich werde mich mal daran erinnern,
dass ich am Ende
von den Folgen immer noch mal kurz unsere Kontaktmöglichkeiten
aufziehen werde. Also
gerne auch unseren akronymisierbar
Matrix-Channel.
Wo finde ich denn jetzt die Adresse von dem
konkret raus? Der heißt
akronymisierbar auf matrix.org
Home-Server. Achso.
Raute akronymisierbar.matrix.org
Genau.
Das ist die
So schreibt man das also.
Nee, eine Fully Qualified Dings ist das auch nicht,
aber das ist zumindest die Adresse im Matrix-Universe.
Matrix-Universe.
Der Matrix-Org-Homeserver hat in letzter Zeit ein bisschen zu schlucken.
Die hatten wohl massive Probleme,
dass die irgendwie von ihrem Hosting-Provider
Kack-Hardware für die Datenbank-Server bekommen haben.
Kack-Hardware.
Ja, richtig Kack-Hardware.
Und das Ding war hart an den Grenzen die letzten Tage,
aber ich habe das auch richtig stark gemerkt.
Nachrichten gingen teilweise minutenlang nicht raus.
das war echt bitter, aber mit Lades läuft es
mittlerweile wieder, wir sind da auch stark hinterher
was besseres zu finden, im besseren
generellen, ich weiß gar nicht wo die hosten, muss ich passen
aber
interessant, aber gut
ist halt auch wieder so ein typisches Problem
du baust was Dezentrales auf
und es gibt diesen einen großen Standard-Home-Server
und da sind halt alle
es ist nicht so ein Problem-Problem, vor allem würde ich fast sagen
dass das Matrix-Universe wirklich recht gut
federated ist
Ja, wir haben jetzt einige Messenger
durchprobiert nach
Wire und jetzt wieder
Signal und Matrix und Telegram.
Ich muss sagen, Matrix ist momentan
mit das Zuverlässigste.
Bei Wire hatte ich den Eindruck, dass
die Nachrichten teilweise irgendwie auch eine Weile
lang nicht ankamen. Was, Wire?
Wire. Ja, nee, ich finde Wire auch
komisch. Wir haben es ja am Anfang
in höchsten Tönen gelobt, weil es einfach
irgendwie auch alles mitbringt und Open Source ist.
Und seit dem Punkt war es gefühlt schon tot als Plattform.
Es hat sich nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Ja, ist ein bisschen schade. Und vor allem die versprochene
Federation, die 2018 kommen sollte.
Wann kamen die gar nicht?
Naja.
Ich habe tatsächlich einen Blogpost von denen gelesen,
dass sie jetzt gerade,
um neue Mitarbeiter zu gewinnen,
ihren Tech-Stack
evaluiert haben und einfach überall
auf die neuesten Sprachen umgestiegen sind.
Ich meine, das ist nett, um neue Mitarbeiter
zu gewinnen, aber
ich meine, persönlich,
ich hätte keinen Bock, an einem iOS-Code-Projekt zu arbeiten,
wo ich nur Objective-C schreibe.
die Zeiten sind vorbei, wir haben schließlich
2019. Genau, wir haben das 21.
Jahrhundert und nicht mehr die 50er.
Die 50er?
Nee, da kannst du auch kein Objective-C, oder?
Nee, keine Ahnung. Nee, Objective-C ist relativ neu.
Das war jetzt Spaß.
Aber ist das
so ein Erfolgskonzept
von wegen, lass mal unsere ganzen Projekte
auf neue Sprachen
umziehen, nicht mal, also nicht
neue Frameworks nutzen, sondern
auf neue Sprachen umziehen. Sie haben
irgendwie TypeScript jetzt statt Java-Skript
für den Webkram, Swift statt Objective-C,
Kotlin statt Java.
Das war so das, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Ich meine, cool, schön, aber
wow, das ist ja,
habt ihr ja cool gemacht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so,
ich will auch nicht drauf umhelfen.
Aber das ist das Einzige, was ich von Wire gehört habe in letzter Zeit
und ansonsten passiert da gefühlt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was die machen.
Und für mich ist Matrix einfach, ich weiß, wir haben das schon oft gesagt,
aber das ist halt das Protokoll, was halt wirklich
zukunftstauglich ist.
und nicht wie alles andere
halt irgendwo in seinem eigenen Container lebt
und dahin rottet.
Einzige, was wir halt nicht haben, sind Clients.
Das ist halt echt immer noch schade.
Ich hab letztens tatsächlich angefangen,
weil ich glaube, wie du darüber schon gesprochen hast.
Nee, hast du nicht?
Ich hatte angefangen, den Matrix-Client
zu schreiben. Für meine Plattform,
also für iOS und hab auch
mal ein bisschen umgespielt mit MacOS.
Ich meine, mittlerweile ist es ja übertragbar, dann müsstest du quasi
gleichzeitig den MacOS-Client
Ja, ich hatte erst versucht, das über dieses
Catalyst, ursprünglich
Marzipan, zu bauen,
dass du halt die iOS-App direkt für macOS baust,
aber das ist nicht ganz so geil.
Es wäre halt ein schöner
Quick-Win gewesen, aber
SwiftUI macht es dir jetzt auch nicht schwer, direkt auf macOS
was zu bauen. Es ist zwar vieles buggy,
klar, und es hat auch
seine Ecken, aber es ist trotzdem eine schönere App,
wenn du es direkt auf der Plattform baust und das macht jetzt
nicht so den Riesen-Undersatz. Wie viele Country-Use kannst du da machen?
Ziemlich viel, also je nachdem, was du halt baust,
die App-UI
musst du ein bisschen anpassen, aber so
einzelne Dinge wie in so einer Liste
einzelne Zellen oder so, da kannst du fast alles komplett
re-usen. Das ist ziemlich cool.
Das ist nice. Und das heißt, du kannst
ein Projekt machen, wo zwei unterschiedliche
Apps bei rausfallen, die sich teilweise
gut verteilen? Für sich theoretisch, ja.
So habe ich es noch nicht, weil ich noch
in der sehr harten Anfangsphase
lange, lange Pre-Alpha bin.
Du kannst aktuell
Chats noch nicht entschlüsseln.
Das heißt, du siehst noch, ich müsste aber eigentlich das Matrix SDK für mich mit abnehmen.
Achso, das gibt ein Matrix SDK.
Also eigentlich, ich hatte ja direkt damit angefangen, die App zu schreiben
und habe dann gemerkt, ah scheiße, das Matrix SDK ist ein bisschen weird,
das stürzt ständig ab, wenn du versuchst, es zu benutzen.
Und warum ist das so, wie kann das so crashy sein?
Das ist ein bisschen eigenartig, ich mache keine Magie.
Ich habe einfach nur das Ding gefragt, ob es mir mal alle öffentlichen Räume
auf dem einen Homeserver ausgeben sollte und da soll es doch nicht abschmieren bei.
Und nicht einfach irgendwie, also wirklich crashen.
Das fand ich nervig, deswegen kam ich auf die
glorreiche Idee, hey,
wäre es nicht viel geiler, erstmal deinen eigenen Matrix
API-Wrapper zu schreiben?
Hab damit angefangen, hab gemerkt,
dass die Spec ja eigentlich recht schick ist und das
wäre doch eigentlich echt cool.
Wie sieht denn die Spec aus? Wie spricht man denn mit einem Matrix?
Das ist einfach quasi eine JSON-API.
Über HTTP? Ja.
Sie haben aus sich gestellt,
irgendwann auch andere Protokolle
zu unterstützen. Irgendwas, was halt
möglichst bandwidth-arm ist. Da haben sie auch
einen coolen Talk auf der Fostam gehalten gehabt,
wo sie, ich meine, es waren,
oh, nee,
ich laber, ich bullshit,
sie wollten Nachrichten mit 100
Bitten
verschicken,
irgendwas Absurdes, ich habe jetzt irgendeine Zahl, was noch im Kopf ist,
aber es war auf jeden Fall so lächerlich
kleine Pakete, die sie schicken wollten
und dann haben sie halt irgendwie alles mögliche
rausgeschmissen und irgendwann hat es halt geklappt,
aber ich müsste jetzt echt lügen, ich muss mir das nochmal rausholen.
Also ich bin mal gespannt,
inwiefern das Web
das noch vereinnahmen wird,
wenn wir irgendwann auf HTTP3
ist ja ein normales HTTP
auch sehr gut für so Low-Latency-
Streaming-Geschichten.
Was macht HTTP 3 nochmal?
Bei HTTP 3 machst du
alles über Quick und hast dann quasi
die ganze Zeit einen... Quick?
Quick ersetzt
TCP
ist ein UDP. Achso, stimmt.
Stimmt, das war das. Wir schmeißen TCP
in die Tonne und nutzen UDP für alles. Genau.
Warum ist das eine gute Idee?
Weil es ist nicht direkt
UDP. Möchtest du, dass ich
jetzt darüber ausholen oder wollen wir erstmal
zu Ende reden?
Ich zirkele nochmal kurz zurück zu der Matrix-App,
aber auch erstmal her.
Oder soll ich zuerst die Matrix-App zu Ende bringen?
Mach erstmal die Matrix-App zu Ende,
das ist vielleicht für die Zuhörer angenehmer.
Viel war da jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Ich meinte, ich hab bloß
die App...
Achso, genau.
Ah, fuck, wo war ich denn?
Ich hab die App, die Matrix-Wapper-Library
und den Server hab ich dann nochmal verworfen.
Die Wapper-Library auch nochmal
habe ich doch mit dem iOS-Matrix-SDK
rumgeärgert
und
bastelt das seitdem damit, vor allem, weil es
halt auch so Dinge wie die
Encryption und die Datenbank direkt mit
integriert. Das fand ich recht nett,
um erstmal die App-UI drumherum
zu basteln, bevor ich jetzt wirklich absteige.
Ob ich das jemals machen werde, ist die andere Frage.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich solche Projekte... Ich muss sagen, so eine schöne
UI zu bauen, ist halt immer das, was am
schwierigsten ist. Ja, bisher habe ich mich immer
davor geärgert, davor zurückgehalten,
UIs zu bauen. Ich habe immer angefangen, eine App zu schreiben.
Ja, dann brauchst du erstmal hier irgendwie deine
Datentypen, die du so durch die Kante wirfst,
was du so einen Datenbank ablegst. Genau, dann hast du schon eine APL gemacht,
freust dich und denkst, so eine App kann jemand anders bauen.
Ja, das ist prinzipiell genauso, weil die UI hat keinen Spaß
gemacht, aber mit SwiftUI ist es wirklich so,
die UI ist halt super easy und es macht auch Spaß
und du kannst halt so schnell iterieren.
Das ist halt, vorher war das so,
ja, jetzt muss ich hier, allein schon so simple Dinge,
wie du hast auf einer iOS-App eine Liste
und du musst diesen Zellen anhalten. Oh, jetzt ist es so nervig,
da eine zwei Zelle reinzuköpfen, die irgendwie
anders aussieht,
da noch zig Teilen Code schreiben, nee, lass mal einfach mal,
das passt schon so, wie es ist und jetzt ist einfach so, ja klar,
ich mach einfach da noch ein Stack rein und das
Label, der passt, sieht wunderbar aus. Ich glaube auch,
wie hübsch UIs sind,
ist eine Funktion davon, wie einfach das
Framework dahinter zu bedienen ist.
Gewagter Aussage, aber da ist potenziell echt was dabei.
Wenn ich mich zurückerinnere,
meine paar wenigen Versuche, die ich
oder Exkursionen
in das Desktop-GUI-Land,
die ich unternommen habe mittels
GTK oder mit Qt,
ist immer darauf hinausgelaufen, dass ich das
geringstmögliche gemacht habe, weil es
einfach total stürrisch war.
Und jetzt bastle ich
immer mal kleine Demonstratoren,
also nicht wirklich Anwendungen, aber
ich habe zum Beispiel eine
WebRTC-Demo gebaut, wo man sich
so durch den Signaling-Flow von einer WebRTC-Session
mal durchklicken kann,
wie die eine Peer-Connection mit der anderen
Kontakt aufnimmt und was die so austauschen
und wie dann plötzlich das fließt.
Das habe ich mit Svelte gebaut und das macht einfach
Fates. Und jetzt momentan bastle ich
ich an einem Demonstrator für
unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten von
Web-Audio und da
das macht
auch super viel, jetzt da einfach
das Zeug so hin und her zu stecken. Das macht
richtig viel aus, wenn
du, und das wird bei SwiftUI
ja genauso sein, wenn du einfach was hast, was sich
schön anfühlt, dann
bist du viel mehr dabei, irgendwie
darüber zu iterieren und die UI zu machen.
Vor allem, wenn du halt schnell und einfach
Dinge machst, du meinst das uneinfacht, aber
die Geschwindigkeit tut halt auch was zur Sache.
Es ist super nervig, wenn du versuchst, ein Herbst zu bauen,
selbst wenn du dir maximal ein Mew gibst und du musst
immer, hier, jetzt ändere ich die Farbe mal
oder die Textgröße einfach zwei Pointgröße,
baust es neu, wartest zwei Minuten,
klickst dich durch drei Panels durch,
ah, so sieht das jetzt aus, okay, gehst du mal zurück,
vielleicht doch noch ein Pointgröße, das geht halt nicht.
Ich meine, deshalb gewinnen
ja auch so Frameworks wie Flutter, wo du so ein Hot Reload
drin hast, was einfach geil ist,
so zu arbeiten. Und SwiftUI
kann halt diese coolen Previews jetzt und
ich meine, die sind auch manchmal buggy und manchmal
mein Lüfter fährt die ganze Zeit stark hoch,
wenn ich die nutze. Aber es macht
so unglaublich viel mehr Spaß damit.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Nee, genau. Jetzt erklär mal bitte Quick.
Also, ich werde dazu
mal einen Vortrag von dem
Haxe, wie heißt
er? Aber du kannst mir nicht erzählen.
Daniel Stenberg. Nee, doch. Genau.
Du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass ich noch nicht
über Quick geredet habe in diesem Podcast.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Daniel Stenberg.
Ich gebe mal einen Vortrag oder
einen Blogpost von Daniel Stenberg, dem
Curl-Entwickler zu Protokoll, der
darüber erzählt hat, warum machen wir jetzt
Quick. Und
der ist hauptsächlich darauf eingegangen,
jetzt wo wir aus HTTP
HTTP 2 gemacht haben,
was ja schon so ein bisschen die Übergänge
zwischen
den unterschiedlichen OSI-Layern
so ein bisschen zum Verschwimmen bringen. Das ist eigentlich
so der große Kritikpunkt
an HTTP 2, dass es irgendwie
mehrere Layer-Funktionalitäten auf einmal
mitbringt.
Was jetzt noch dazu kommt, ist, dass du
immer noch über eine TCP-Verbindung,
die du eventuell länger offen hältst,
dann oben drüber
ein Abstraktionslayer, oben drüber
Streams hast, HTTP-Streams,
wo du
zum Beispiel HTML-Dateien oder Bilder
oder Skripte, die unterschiedlichen Artefakter
von deiner Webseite alle so in Streams miteinander
schickst. Und dazwischen hast du aber, weil du immer noch
HTTPS bist, hast du noch dein
TLS-Layer.
Und da gibt es
den Vortrag, den er
vor drei, vier Jahren gehalten hat, als ich da war,
hat sich hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt.
Wir haben diese unterschiedlichen Layer.
Wir haben einen TCP-Layer,
wo wir Pakete dieser Größe hin und her schicken.
Oben drüber ein SSL-Layer, wo wir Pakete
dieser Größe hin und her schicken.
Und oben drüber ein Layer HTTP2,
wo wir Pakete dieser Länge hin und her schicken.
Und wenn diese Packages
nicht alignen und du unten drunter
ein TCP-Paket verlierst,
dann
zerreichst du vielleicht oben drüber
ein halbes SSL oder zwei Drittel
von zwei unterschiedlichen
DDP-Paketen.
Und da ist es dir eigentlich,
geht es dir auf den Sack, wenn dann dein
System,
wenn dein TCP sowas wie
Retransmission betreibt.
Weil es einfach, du musst dann darauf warten, dass sich
alle diese drei Streams wieder synchronisiert haben
mit den Paketen, die du verloren hast und
nachgeschickt hast. Wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert.
Und deswegen ist jetzt die Frage, eigentlich könnte
man sowas wie TCP
mal weiterentwickeln
und ein bisschen ein paar von diesen
hartgecodeten Garantien,
die da mit drin sind, zum Beispiel
Retransmission oder
das Bandwidth Management, was da mit drin ist.
Das könnte man mal überdenken und mal
neu entwickeln. Problem,
das Internet ist voll mit
Hardware-Routern, die können
alle UDP und TCP.
Wir können jetzt nicht einfach
ein neues Protokoll ausrollen.
Das geht nicht.
Klar, dann kann man den ganzen Cisco rotzendlich in die Tonne kippen.
Würde
wahrscheinlich nie passieren.
Natürlich nicht.
Und deswegen hat man sich gedacht,
gut, wir bauen jetzt ein neues Protokoll
auf UDP-Basis.
Das sieht dann für
Teilnehmer,
die einfach bloß irgendwo
dazwischen sind, irgendwie
dein Router irgendwo beim
D6 oder irgendwo
in irgendeiner Verwaltungsstelle, der eigentlich
seit Jahren dasteht und eigentlich immer noch
völlig ausreicht, sieht das einfach aus wie
UDP-Traffic. Und sowas wie
Retransmission und Bandwidth-Kontrolle, was in UDP
nicht drin ist, machen wir
auf
Software-Seite. Machen wir nicht als Teil von
dem Protokoll. Also es sieht nach unten aus
wie UDP, aber oben drüber hat es dann Features,
die
TCP zum Beispiel unterscheiden.
Das ist jetzt nicht eine wirkliche Mischung, das ist eine
tolle Vereinfachung, aber im Endeffekt
das ist das nächste Protokoll, was sehr
viele Sachen abbildet.
Genau.
Jetzt gibt es Überlegungen, dass man
quick benutzt, um
andere Protokolle zu beerben.
Zum Beispiel, was in WebRTC drin ist,
da ist ja die einzige
Art und Weise, wie dein Webbrowser einen
UDP-Socket zu einem anderen
Server oder einem anderen Browser aufmachen kann,
ist über diese
WebRTC-Data-Channels oder überhaupt
WebRTC-Channels.
Ansonsten kannst du keine UDP-Sockets
aus deinem Browser aufmachen. Ist eigentlich auch ganz gut,
weil sonst könntest du irgendwo Skripte indizieren,
die dann, was weiß ich,
NTP in
JavaScript geschrieben. Nein.
Warum? Und damit andere Sachen
dossen. Oh Gott, klingt das schrecklich.
Du willst aber trotzdem manchmal
Protokolle bauen,
die die Eigenschaften von UDP haben.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du Medien überträgst.
Okay, ja.
Und deswegen gibt es gerade
so ein bisschen Entwicklungen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel
dieses
Web Transport Proposal.
Das ist jetzt hier so ein Draft. Das kann ich mir auch mit
in die Shownotes tun. Das
Es liegt jetzt halt, gut, okay, wenn wir jetzt HTTP 3 haben, könnten wir vielleicht so eine Art Web-Socket-Ersatz haben, was mir erlaubt, einen rohen Quick-Socket irgendwo anders hin aufzumachen.
Und darüber dann zum Beispiel Medien schicken, ohne dass wir WebRTC sprechen müssen zum Beispiel. Das sind so Bestrebungen.
sind es auch in dieser ganzen WebRTC-Szene
ist die gesamte Diskussion so ein bisschen umstritten.
Da loomt gerade so am Horizont die böse Bedrohung.
Erstens WebAssembly und zweitens Quick
und dieses WebTransport-Proposal,
weil du damit nämlich komplett WebRTC ersetzen könntest.
Das ist nett.
Du könntest jetzt hingehen und sagen,
für so Medientransport brauche ich eigentlich
keinen Browser mehr mit WebRTC.
Ich brauche bloß noch diese
Quick-Transporte und dann
kompiliere ich meine ganzen
Codecs und mein Signaling, alles was
irgendwie, also wirklich proprietäre Codecs
meinetwegen, alles nach WebAssembly.
Und dann haben wir,
können wir so Sachen machen wie WebRTC
bloß ohne, dass es Open Source ist.
Ohne Open Standards.
Das ist so ein bisschen verwerflich.
Also interessant für Leute,
die proprietäre Software in dem Bereich
machen. Aber
trotzdem weiterhin ein bisschen verwerflich
oder zumindest ein bisschen bedenklich.
Aber
naja, das ist so das, was ich
so als kleines Forschungsprojekt auch nebenbei
bei uns immer noch so ein bisschen
interessant finde.
Klingt auf jeden Fall cool. Darf ich an der Stelle was
darf ich an der Stelle was pluggen?
Natürlich. Und zwar habe ich
ja das letzte Mal erzählt, dass wir überlegt haben,
einen Meetup-Account
zu hijacken. Das haben wir
natürlich nicht gemacht.
Aber wir organisieren jetzt in Dresden,
also wir, das heißt ich und die Firma,
für die ich arbeite, organisieren jetzt in Dresden
ein bislang erstmal einmaliges
Meetup und zwar,
dass...
Einmalig meinst du, es findet nur einmal statt und es ist nicht...
Genau, also wir machen jetzt keinen, wir haben uns
einen neuen Meetup-Account angelegt und
wir organisieren
erstmal nur ein Event darüber,
die anderen sind noch nachfolgend geplant. Also es gibt noch irgendwie
andere Meetups, die wir
hosten, jetzt wird im November irgendwie
nochmal das C++ Meetup irgendwie bei
meiner Firma zu Besuch sein, wo dann
einer von uns redet. Aber wir
organisieren am 21.
November das
WebRTC Community Dresden
Meetup. Cool.
Link ist in den Shownotes.
Da werden
wir ein bisschen erzählen,
wie wir auf Arbeit
WebRTC einsetzen. Und dann gibt es noch
eine Konferenz, die kurz davor in
San Francisco gewesen sein wird.
Das ist
Foodhook 2. Ja, die ist irgendwie
drei Tage vorher. Und da
Schauen wir einfach gemeinsam die Vorträge von dort.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Nee, klingt toll. Gute Idee.
Oder danke fürs Organisieren.
Vielleicht kommt ja ein sehr cooles Mitarbeiter zustande.
Ja, mir ist ja bei der ganzen
Programmplanung so ein bisschen
in Vergessenheit geraten,
dass ich genau für den Abend noch Konzerttickets hatte.
Ungünstig.
Ungünstig. Also wenn jemand
Konzertkarten für ein Christoph Reuter Konzert
hat, wenn ich nicht an dem
Lied abteiligen möchte, dann könnte er mir
bitte Bescheid sagen.
genau
so viel dazu
ich hatte gerade noch mal
Wasm erwähnt
noch mal vielen Dank an das Feedback aus
unserem Riot Channel, ich weiß nicht genau
wer es geschrieben hatte, wir haben den Link
aber auch noch aus anderen Quellen tatsächlich bekommen
war das der Mick
oder war das der Stefan
oder, ne das war Magnesium wieder
vielen Dank
Recent studies estimated
50% of websites using
WebAssembly applied for malicious
Purpose ist. Das ist schon herrlich.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Aber wenn ich mir das Bild von Magnesium
so angucke, dann
sieht der aus, als ob er sich damit auskennt.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Hacker-Bild.
Sonnenbrille.
Sieht aus wie eine Hoodie noch drumherum.
Eindeutig ganz viel das Hacker-Bildschirm.
Reflexion vom Bildschirm in der Sonnenbrille.
Ist tatsächlich so,
dass sie irgendwie festgestellt haben,
sie sind nicht wirklich genau drauf eingegangen, was sie machen,
aber viele setzen
WebAssembly so für
Crypto-Miner und für
was war das andere?
Die Sachen, die halt schön optimiert auch gut laufen.
Kannst ja mehr Geld mitmachen, wenn es besser läuft.
Ja, ich meine, wenn der Crypto-Miner bei mir
lokal läuft und
damit ein bisschen Ressourcen spart, ist ja nicht ganz angenehm.
Ja, nicht spart, der nutzt nur mehr.
Ja, eigentlich.
Ist doch noch besser für den Crypto-Miner.
Achso, genau, für Crypto-Mining und für
einfach Obfuscation.
Logisch, das ist natürlich sehr guter Obfuscation.
Du kannst trotzdem
im WebAssembly-Modul,
klar, du kannst die interne Logik
verstecken, was es macht, aber zum Beispiel,
worauf es zugreift und was es alles machen kann,
das kannst du dem Ding ja trotzdem ansehen, weil es immer noch
eine JavaScript-Schnittstelle nach außen hat.
Also du musst es dem Ding ansehen können,
ob es Websockets aufmacht, ob es
auf irgendwelche Webseiten zugreift,
ob es irgendwas irgendwo hinschickt, ob es
irgendwie deinen Keyboard-Events
mitliest oder sowas.
Naja, immerhin, aber
das ist halt, wenn man nicht nachvollziehen kann, was das Ding eigentlich tut.
Da fällt mir ein, dass ich eigentlich immer mal
bei so Facebook oder so
einen Websocket-Transport
monitoren wollte, oder diesen
Network-Monitor anmachen wollte,
was irgendwie hieß, dass die mittracken,
welche Artikel du dir wie lange
anguckst. Das wundere ich mich überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen würde mich mal interessieren, ob der irgendwie
müsst ihr quasi während ich durch
Facebook durchscrolle,
irgendwas wegschicken, wie lange ich mir
jetzt gerade welche Artikel
angeguckt habe. Kann man das nicht sogar vielleicht
irgendwie serverseitig machen?
was du da raussurfst
anhalten. Ich meine,
das wäre natürlich viel besser aufsichtlicherweise
Kleintseite. Du könntest das darüber machen, was ich gerade
nachlade, während ich runterscrolle.
Und wenn ich nicht mehr nachlade, dann habe ich mir offenbar das
Letzte, was ich geladen habe,
am längsten. Aber das muss nicht sein. Es kann ja sein, dass ich wieder
hochscrolle und mir dann was anderes angucke.
Je nachdem, wie die... Ja, egal.
Aber ja, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass die
das tracken, weil das ist ja relativ relevant
für die.
Okay.
Das ist nicht mehr
verwunderlich bei Facebook.
Genau.
Du hast ja GitHub Actions noch auf die Liste gesetzt.
Da habe ich letztens eine Mail bekommen.
Ist das jetzt irgendwie komplett public?
Nee, das ist glaube ich immer noch Beta.
Mir sind ein paar Repos aufgefallen, wo Leute schon anfangen,
so GitHub Actions für unterschiedliche,
sich Rust GitHub Actions oder sowas
zusammenzustellen. Und ich hatte neulich
mal festgestellt, dass selbst auf meinen eigenen Repos,
die, wo ich jetzt über
für ein Hektoberfest
Pull-Requests bekommen habe,
da gehen zwar Pull-Requests auf,
aber ich bin noch nicht automatisch als
Reviewer assigned, obwohl ich der einzige
Projekt-Owner bin.
Und wenn du nicht als Reviewer assigned bist
und das quasi mal anguckst und als gelesen markierst,
dann verschwindet es irgendwie für GitHub.
Ja, das ist so ein Feature, was viele Leute bei GitHub
mängeln. Und eigentlich müsstest du dann dementsprechend,
wenn du so ein Repo aufmachst, immer dann noch
dich selber erstmal als Reviewer hinzufügen,
damit das in deiner Aktivitätsliste irgendwie
immer drin bleibt oder sowas. Deswegen habe ich
mal überlegt, kann ich da nicht einfach bei GitHub irgendwie,
kann man nicht konfigurieren, dass man automatisch
Reviewer hinzugefügt wird. Das wäre eigentlich
so eine Default-Reviewer-Liste.
Das habe ich oftmals nicht gefunden.
So ein Code-Owners-Feature. Ist das nicht sogar dafür mitgedacht,
dass man sagt, für welche Bereiche wer
Code-Owners und die Personen werden automatisch...
Dann ziehe ich mir so eine Code-Owners-Datei mit einem
Sternchen rein und schreibe meinen Namen rein
quasi als eine Zeile.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen nutzlos.
Also für solche Sachen gibt es zumindest auch
GitHub-Actions, dass du nämlich, wenn
ein Pre-Request aufgehst, sagst
Notification über diesen Channel und bitte
diese Person als Reviewer
hinzufügen. Habe ich überlegt, dass ich
das mal einrichten wollte, aber ich habe es noch nicht wirklich gemacht.
Ich habe es
hiermit auf die Liste genommen, weil ich dich fragen wollte, ob du
schon was damit gemacht hast. Ich habe bisher bloß
ein paar kleinen Zwift-Paketen,
die absolut unbedeutend sind, mal getestet, wie das
denn wäre mit quasi
so einem Basic-CI-Workflow von wegen
baut das noch, füllen wir die Tests aus,
gibt es da irgendwie einen anderen Exit-Code?
Genau.
Aber ersetzt das dann sowas wie
Travis? Ja.
Also das ist wirklich alles, was ich mit GitHub Actions bisher gemacht habe.
Quasi den winzigen Travis-Workflow
abbilden. Und wo
baut das dann? Auch bei
Travis? Nee, nee, das läuft schon immer dann über,
wo immer GitHub Actions laufen, auf irgendwelchen Microsoft
Azure-Servern. Ach, okay, witzig.
Okay, also es macht also wesentlich mehr.
Ich dachte, dass... Also es
könnte quasi also meine komplette CI
setzen. Klar, also du kannst komplett...
Theoretisch kannst du ja machen, was du möchtest.
Du hast ja jetzt dann auch die coolen Hooks, dass du halt so Sachen
machen kannst, wie Reviewer
übersetzen. Genau. Ich glaube
irgendwie, was kannst du denn noch machen?
Ich hatte zum Beispiel auch gemacht, dass ich
wenn ich ein Tag
angebe, dass es
dann bitte gebaut und released wird.
Das war über
Travis ziemlich frickelig, weil du musstest
dann irgendwie in dein Travis-Config
einen
API-Key für das Repo mit
einchecken. Klar. Und
Release meinst du, ein Release auf GitHub anlegen,
also ein Tag anlegen, dazu noch ein
Release anlegen mit dem Tag und dann noch
anhängen. Genau, genau. Du kannst ja bei GitHub
bei einem Release, also ein Tag,
ein Release ist ein Tag, du kannst aber, wenn du
Releases gemacht hast, noch Bild-Artefakte mit
dranhängen. Ja, dann musst du ja dieses Release-Release noch dazu
an das Tag anhängen. Genau, genau.
Und das hatte ich zum Beispiel für diese Ascii-Invoise gemacht.
Ich hab's festgestellt, dass ich das irgendwie offenbar vor ein paar
Versionen wieder kaputt gemacht habe, auf irgendeine Art und
Weise. Und das zu testen und
zu einrichten, ist super nervig.
Und wenn's da einfach einen fertigen,
was weiß ich, es gibt ein Repo,
das heißt Actions RS, das sind dann,
Das ist auch noch nicht ganz ausgeprägt.
Aber wenn es da irgendwann eine Einschätzung gibt,
dass ich sage, wenn ich einen Tag mache
oder wenn irgendeine Bedingung eintrifft,
dann baue mir das für diese fünf Targets
und lade mir das als Binary hoch.
Das fände ich schon ziemlich geil.
Ziemlich.
Ist natürlich witzig.
GitHub ist eine coole Plattform nach wie vor.
Aber es ist auch witzig, was da jetzt alles passiert.
Und gleichzeitig, dass das natürlich in der Hand von Microsoft liegt.
Es hat immer so einen Fadenbeigeschmack.
Also ich finde es cool, wenn GitHub weiter wächst.
Ich finde es cool, wenn GitHub coole Videos einbaut,
aber dieser Fadenbeigeschmack bleibt irgendwo.
Gleichzeitig habe ich letztens ein anderes
cooles Microsoft-Projekt für mich entdeckt,
was ich auch sehr toll finde.
Und zwar ist das AppCenter.ms.
Das scheint noch relativ neu zu sein.
Das ist auch so eine Art
continuous
CI und CD-Plattform für Apps.
Wenn das mal nicht das
Backend für...
App-zentrisch, ja. Das ist ziemlich
App-zentrisch, ja. Und zwar kannst du
da einfach quasi, also ich glaube
ich, ein Nachfolger, die haben auch das, was sie
früher mal als Hockey-App gekauft und dann weiter
vertreten haben, dadurch
jetzt abgelöst. Hockey-App.
Genau, Hockey war so eine
Plattform, wo Leute ihre
Beta-Bilds mitunter verteilen konnten und ich glaube auch
noch ein paar mehr Dinge, aber habe ich nicht genutzt.
Nur mal ein paar Mal ist
Nutzer von irgendwelchen Beta-Sachen.
Das hat aber auch so eine richtig geile animierte
Startseite Hockey-App, wo
schwebt. Und jedenfalls
das App Center ist halt super easy in der Nutzung.
Das finde ich da schon ein bisschen geil dran. Ich habe ja
diese Mensa-App, die ich geschrieben habe, einfach mal mit dem GitHub
Beaver verknüpft. Seitdem wird einfach jeder
Commit auf Master direkt gebaut.
Jeder Commit auf Master wird, weil ich
noch ein Development-Zertifikat mit
reingeladen habe, automatisch ein Bild gemacht.
Also wirklich ein Bild. Und dieser
Bild wird dann hochgeladen zu Apples Testflight.
Und ich kriege ein paar
Minuten nach dem Push auf meinem Handy eine Notification
von wegen Testflight. Dieser Bild ist jetzt verfügbar.
Und es ist so wenig Aufwand,
Vor allem, das war einfach, bei anderen
CI-Lösungen für iOS-Kram musst du halt immer
sagen. Ja, das ist gerade von Hockey oder von
AppCenter. Der Hockey ist, wie gesagt, mit
quasi Tod jetzt, wird durch AppCenter abgelöst.
Bei anderen Lösungen war das immer so
eine Frickelarbeit.
Travis Bound ist
unglaublich mühsam gewesen.
Hier war das halt wirklich so, wo liegt denn deine App?
Dieses GitHub-Ibc. Okay, wir bauen sie schon.
Was?
Da war
null weitere Konflikt dabei, das fand ich schon ein bisschen
beeindruckend.
Für die meisten Apps kann man sich die Bildinstruktion ja auch herleiten.
Ja, genau das machen sie halt.
Sie versuchen schlau zu sein und die Standardkonfiguration verstehen sie halt.
Und das läuft verdammt gut.
Und das Einzige, was halt nicht geht, finde ich sauber,
ist, dass du halt direkt Release-Bilds machst für den Store.
Könntest du theoretisch auch einrichten, das ist ein Haken.
Aber ich sehe keine Möglichkeit,
wie ich auf App-Center-Localization für die Release-Nodes machen kann.
Und so könnte ich die nur in einer Sprache eingeben.
Und wenn eine Sprache, dann muss es natürlich Englisch sein.
Aber ich habe auch,
zumindest Deutsch und Englisch mache ich halt gerne,
gerade für eine App, die hier für
Dresden relevant ist, würde halt schon
Sinn ergeben. Und das finde ich ein bisschen
schade, aber die Release-Bilds
selber machen hin und wieder. Die Builds werden ja automatisch
hochgeladen und mit dem Release-X-Code gebaut.
Das heißt, ich kann direkt eigentlich jederzeit
ins App-Store-Backend gehen, in diese App-Store-Connect
und sagen, dieser Build ist jetzt bitte Store fertig.
Macht da mal Version X raus.
Das ist raus. Natürlich natürlich
das Review, aber das war's. Mehr muss ich
nicht machen. Die Builds sind alle da und ich muss die nicht mehr
hochladen. Und es ist schon besser geworden
über die Jahre und es läuft erstaunlich gut mittlerweile,
über X-Rot hochzuladen, aber es ist immer noch mühsam.
Und das ist echt nice. Und ich bin nicht immer noch gespannt,
was Apple irgendwann vielleicht mal mit der
... Die haben ja so eine Einnahme ins Buddybild mal gekauft
gehabt. Ja, Buddybild.
Cooler Name.
Vielleicht kommt ja da irgendwann noch was Cooles raus.
Irgendwas, was Apple und
Services, wenn die da wieder so
ein Ding machen wie, ich weiß nicht,
du kennst wahrscheinlich das App Store Connect, beziehungsweise iTunes Connect,
beziehungsweise Podcast Connect.
Die Plattform von denen nicht so geil.
nicht so gut. Die sind alle,
die sind ansehnlich
auf ihre eigene Art und
Weise, aber unglaublich kacke
in der Medellinung. Sie sind schon einen Riesenschritt
vorwärts zu dem, was es vorher war,
aber boah, sind die lahm.
Und das, also jedes Mal, ist immer
so ein Beigeschack von wegen,
ja, hier, ich gehe da jetzt mal drauf. Okay, die nächsten 10 Minuten
klicke ich mich jetzt ja einfach durch UI.
Ach.
Aber dieses
App Center ist jetzt
wirklich für iOS-Apps, Android-Apps,
Windows-Apps, React-Native-Apps,
sogar Xamarin-Apps
und noch
macOS, tvOS, Cordoba.
Sogar Flutter geht.
Das ist nicht gelistet, aber es geht wohl auch.
Die geben sich da echt Mühe, eine coole Plattform zu schaffen.
Das finde ich echt erstaunlich, wie gut es läuft.
Ja, sie wollen irgendwie
Microsoft hat
seine Strategie gefunden, seine neue.
Nachdem sie halt festgestellt haben,
mit Betriebssystemen kannst du
halt niemanden mehr hinterm Ofen hervorlocken.
machen Windows noch weiter so als Baseline,
damit es das gibt.
Die verdienen sicherlich noch gut Geld damit, aber
ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das auch kostenlos wird.
Aber dass die jetzt
Windows für Mobile eingestellt haben,
das hat keinen
gejuckt und dadurch, dass sie sich
jetzt im Open-Source-Umfeld, gerade mit
solchen Aktionen oder mit dem sie einfach
GitHub unterstützen, verdient machen
oder mit so Projekten wie
Visual Studio selber, Visual Studio Code,
sind sie halt der Player in dem Bereich.
Ja, interessanterweise,
Sie haben quasi den gesamten Stack von Editor bis
Released quasi durch, ohne irgendwie
eine eigene Plattform zu haben, was sehr witzig ist.
Bis auf Windows selber. Aber
es ist immer noch so eine sehr zweigeteilte
Firma. Sie machen den coolen,
auf der einen Seite sehr viel Open Source,
sehr viel richtig coole Software, die richtig gut läuft.
Auf der anderen Seite werbeverseucht ist Windows
mit sehr viel Telemetry, die gesammelt wird
und Nutzer abholt.
Was ist denn das für eine Firma? Ich meine, das eine ist
alt eingesessen, das läuft schon immer so,
wird immer ein bisschen beschissen und das andere ist relativ
neu und einfach geil.
wem vertraue ich denn da? Setze ich da wirklich
drauf, dass das cooles Zeug ist und nutze
ich da vieles von? Ich meine, an GitHub
komme ich gefühlt eh nicht vorbei.
Da fällt mir mein erster GitHub-Star
ein. Den ziehe ich mal
vor. Nice.
Nachdem wir jetzt, wo wir jetzt gerade bei dem Team sind.
Das ist schon die Microsoft-Werbung, die wir hier machen.
Deswegen empfehle ich,
ich habe es selber noch nicht ausprobiert, muss ich gestehen.
Wir benennen unsere GitHub-Stars immer wieder zu Picks um.
Auch wenn wir meistens nur GitHub-Stars haben,
können wir doch lieber Picks.
Also ich habe da einen Pick, den ziehe ich jetzt mal vor.
auf GitHub habe ich gestartet.
Und zwar ist das
VS Codeium.
Okay.
Und das ist quasi, was
Chromium zu Chrome ist,
ist das VS Code
Build. It's not a fork.
Das ist,
this is not a fork, this is a repository of
scripts to automatically build
Microsoft's VS Code
repository into a freely licensed
binaries with
a community-driven default configuration.
Das ist einfach dann, das baut dir ein VS Code.
Allerdings
auch ohne
diesen Telemetry-Teil, der auch in VS Code
drin ist.
Da ist es auch drin. Aber nicht so schlimm wie ein Windows,
glaube ich. Ich muss es mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe es tatsächlich hier in die Liste geschmissen, aber selber noch nicht ausprobiert.
Hat auch ein ganz hübsches
Logo, sieht nicht aus wie so ein Goldfisch, der irgendwie
verknotet ist, sondern eher wie so eine Koralle.
Das ist echt ein schickes Logo. Das gefällt mir sehr.
Ich werde
das demnächst mal ausprobieren und dann kann ich noch mal
ein bisschen Feedback dazu geben. Aber das ist so eine Empfehlung,
mir jemand zugeschoben hat. Aber das ist eine tolle Idee.
Chromium empfehle ich auch immer
allen Leuten, die Chrome nutzen.
Wenn du schon den Browser nutzen möchtest,
nutzt du wenigstens die freiere Variante
ohne den Google-Scheiß.
Ja, aber...
Du bist der, der Ahnung vom Browser nutzt.
Sag mir, warum das eine schlechte Idee ist.
Nee, es ist nicht unbedingt eine schlechte Idee.
Ich muss zugeben, ich benutze Chrome
auch nur zum Debuggen.
Ich würde es auch nie privat nutzen.
Selbst Chromium
ist einfach nicht komplett frei.
es nicht so, dass die bei Google
Chromium entwickeln und dann
erst ihren Google-eigenen
Telemetry-Scheiß einbauen und es dann erst Chrome
nennen. Ich habe mir bloß
so einen Erfahrungsbericht, ich habe ja auch hier auf meinem Laptop
dieses Edge Canary
Stickerchen draufgeklebt,
weil ich mich auf dem JS-Kongress
mit ein paar Edge-Entwickler unterhalten habe
und die mir gesagt haben, ach ja, Chromium,
wir sind erst mal hingegangen und haben
dann aus dem Chromium-Code ganz viel
so Google-Zeugs rausgeschmissen,
was da immer noch drin war mit so
da gab es irgendwie...
So halb wie wir es ingeniert, oder?
Nee, nee, die haben einfach das Ding genommen und
setzen ihr eigenes
Ding drauf und haben vorher ein paar Sachen noch rausgeschmissen,
die Google-spezifisch sind. Also die haben
aus Chromium noch Google-Zeugs
rausgeschmissen.
Dummerweise haben sie dann halt
auch irgendwann relativ viel Microsoft-Zeugs
reingeschmissen. Also jetzt hast du jetzt nicht, das Edge
ist nicht das noch
leichtere Chromium, sondern dafür hast
du jetzt die Microsoft-Tracker dort
wieder drin. Was man
Was man eigentlich haben möchte, ist ein Chrome quasi.
Kein Chrome, auch kein Chromium,
sondern irgendwas, was Chromium nimmt
und da diese letzten Reste von Google rauswirft,
die man dann als Baseline nehmen könnte.
Aber das gibt es, glaube ich, nicht.
Also selbst Chromium ist nicht Google-frei.
Ist es nicht.
Aber eine gewisse Art und Weise von Telemetry
ist ja schon irgendwie auch für die Entwickler wichtig.
einen schönen
alternativen Namen,
dafür habe ich neulich von einem Kollegen von mir gehört,
das ist halt einfach nicht der Chrome Webbrowser,
das ist der Google Native Client.
Oh, das ist
echt gut. Das ist quasi der Client
für alle Google-Produkte. Das ist echt
gut. Es ist auch nicht wirklich ein Browser,
weil wenn du die, also nebenbei ist es auch noch
ein Webbrowser, aber wenn du damit
die Google-Webseiten
besuchst, das ist ja kein Web,
das ist ja
bereits jetzt quickbasiertes,
nicht standardkonformes
HTTP. Stimmt, das ist echt on point.
Ist ja auch so witzig, wenn du Chrome nutzt
und dich in irgendwelche Google-Services anmeldet, plötzlich
bist du im Browser angemeldet.
Ja, das finde ich super eklig auch.
Aber das ist echt
staunlich on point. Googles Webseiten
machen mit Chrome andere Dinge
als mit anderen Browsern.
Ja.
Ja, deswegen funktionieren
ja auch leider so Seiten wie
YouTube einfach besser in Chrome.
Das war dieses Ding, wo die davor,
wenn du mit Edge YouTube angesurft hast,
dass so ein unsichtbares Diff vor dem Video war,
dass der irgendwie der Hardware-Decoder
für das Video nicht angesprochen ist oder so.
Die Geschichte kenne ich nicht, aber ich glaube es.
Da haben die Edge-Entwickler irgendwie drüber gerantet.
Man kann natürlich da jetzt Verschwörungstheorien anbringen,
aber ich weiß nicht, was da war.
Das war irgendwie super weird.
Apropos Verschwörungstheorien.
Hast du gelesen,
Dresden hat den Nazi-Notstand ausgerufen.
habe ich gestern irgendwo mitbekommen.
Was genau sei es passiert?
Das ist einfach ein Beschluss vom Stadtrat gewesen.
Das kam irgendwie gestern über MDR.
Der Begriff Nazi-Notstand in Dresden ist natürlich ein bisschen hart.
Aber eigentlich heißt es hier, der Dresdner Stadtrat
eine Grundsatzerklärung gegen Rechtsextremismus verabschiedet.
Der Antrag wurde mit einer Mehrheit von 39 Stimmen aus dem Lager der SPD,
Linken, Grün, der fraktionslosen
Stadträte und auch der FDP angenommen.
Insgesamt 29 Stadträte votierten
dagegen. Der Stadtrat
stelle, Zitat,
mit besorgnisfest,
dass antidemokratische,
antipluralistische,
menschenfeindliche und extrem
rechte Einstellungen und Taten bis hin
zu Gewalt immer stärker offen
zutage treten.
Und mit diesem
Eintrag, der witzigerweise
ursprünglich von der Partei eingereicht wurde.
macht der, also
eigentlich setzen sie hauptsächlich ein Zeichen
gegen rechtsextreme
Ist das irgendwelche Handlungs
irgendwas Actionables, was dabei
rauskommt? Hier steht auch drin, also
der Artikel geht noch weiter, also ich habe den
in den Show Notes verlinkt, der Artikel geht noch weiter
mit einem Interview mit
dem
Parteimitglied
dessen Namen ich hier gerade nicht finde, der den eingerichtet hat
Achso, Aschenbach heißt der
und
der sagt doch selber, naja, eigentlich interessiert sich
normalerweise kein Mensch für
irgendwelche Stadtrats...
Leider wahr, ja.
Grundsatzerklärung.
Aber hat sich wenigstens
der Stadtrat mal explizit gegen rechts
ausgesprochen und nicht einfach bloß alles so
stuhlschweigend hingenommen und ignoriert.
Ich finde dieses
Nazinotstand im Pad irgendwie nicht
ordentlich lesen. Meine Augen gelesen, dieses
Nazino wie so ein Weiden...
Nazino.
Stand.
Naja, egal. Aber in meinem Recht haben sie
trotzdem und ich finde es schön, dass es nicht irgendwie abgelehnt wurde
durch Regierungsparteien.
Schön fand ich auch den Tweet
von jemandem vorgestern oder gestern.
Genau.
Wenn Norddeutsche
sich für Halloween verkleiden.
Da siehst du ein Bild von
norddeutschen Frauen, die Dirndl anhaben,
so als Halloween-Kostüm, weil es halt gruselig ist.
Das war aber eher so eine Nebenbei-Geschichte.
Geschichte.
Das ist von Jakob Fricke
gewesen. Der ist, glaube ich...
Gruselig und ekelhaft.
Weiß gar nicht genau, wer der ist.
Aber der hatte, witzigerweise, das fand ich einfach lustig,
unten drunter direkt noch geschrieben
Werbeblock.
Hey du, ja du, wo du gerade
schon mal hier bist. Unterschreibe
hier, um Björn Höcke aus dem Beamtenverhältnis
zu entfernen. Der haben wir quasi... Bernd Höcke.
Bernd Höcke meint ihr. Bernd Höcke.
Ne? Bernd Höcke?
Ich weiß nicht,
Ich kriege es einfach nicht mehr gebacken, wie der echt heißt.
Ich will ihn immer mit dem anderen Namen sprechen.
Jetzt bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher, ob Bernd Höcke der falsche Name ist.
Also du darfst ihn sehr gerne Bernd Höcke nennen.
Ach, der heißt Landolf Ladek.
Genau.
Und was mit Landolf Ladek?
Der ist Beamter.
Witzigerweise allerdings in Hessen.
Weil er, glaube ich, ursprünglich aus Hessen kommt oder so.
Warum das denn?
Und weil er Lehrer ist.
Der ist Geschichtslehrer, witzigerweise.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass der Typ Geschichtslehrer ist.
Der Typ. Oh, was hat der denn falsches geraucht?
Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie hier, ich weiß auch nicht, was das für einen Sinn hat,
aber es gibt irgendwie auf campag.de
gibt es eine
Unterschriftensammlung,
mit der gefordert wird, dass der aus dem
Beamtenverhältnis entlassen wird.
Das geht ja auch mal gar nicht.
Mir macht es ja doch, dass der Ahnung Häubchen,
dass er gerade Geschichtslehrer ist.
Ja, ja, der ist Geschichtslehrer, das ist krass.
Geschichtsverklärer.
Passend.
Wie heißt dieses Lehrerverpetsportal von der AfD?
Der als Lehrer wird doch ganz sicherlich nicht unpolitisch bleiben.
Haben sie den,
das Ding haben sie doch schon niedergeklagt, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das haben sie schon für einstweiliger Verfügung,
haben sie das glaube ich schon wieder dicht gemacht.
Ein Tweet gelesen von irgendeiner Lehrerin,
die gar nicht mal was Politisches gesagt hat,
die ihren Schülern gegenüber,
bloß denen ihrer Meinungsbildung auf die Spur geholfen hat,
was menschliche Grundrechte angeht, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Vielleicht drehe ich das auch noch im Kopf,
ich fände den Tweet eh nicht mehr.
Und da hat wohl auch eine Schülerin
des ihrer Mutter in Anführungsstrichen
gepetzt und die war wohl AfD-Wählerin
und ist reingekommen und hat rumgeschrien
und die beleidigt, was das denn
solle, die kann doch nicht hier
irgendwas gegen AfD sagen.
Keine Ahnung, was da...
Als nächstes erzählt ihr uns hier noch was von der Evolution
oder sowas. Ja, um Gottes Willen.
Was völlig meiner religiösen Einstellung
widerspricht. Ja, ist ja auch richtig so.
Evolution gab es nicht.
Nee, nee, was war denn noch?
Also wenn ich da zurückdenke, ich hatte an der
ausdeutschen Schule einen westdeutschen
Geschichtslehrer und wenn der
über den Marxismus geredet hat, musst du eigentlich
alle darüber lachen.
Ich glaube, da musst du einfach als
Schüler auch lernen, die unterschiedlichen
politischen Einstellungen deiner Lehrer
einzuordnen.
Das ist ja auch nicht trivial. Ich meine, als Schüler
sollst du ja explizit in der Schule sein, um
offen zu sein.
Aber Geschichte,
Geschichtsunterricht, also unabhängig davon,
dass Landolf Ladig wahrscheinlich als
Geschichtslehrer
höchstwahrscheinlich Gülle erzählt.
Unabhängig davon ist es ja relativ
schwierig, Geschichte zu vermitteln
und das mit einer
komplett neutralen
Haltung.
Weil Geschichte ist ja quasi
immer auch auf gewisse Art und Weise
interpretierbar. Also
du kannst jetzt natürlich die reinen Fakten runterbeten,
aber allein die Auswahl der
Blickwinkel, die du
triffst, ist ja quasi
schon deutend, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel
Geschichte der
Machtergreifung der Nazis und der
Haft, wie spät haben wir es? Wir reden über Nazis.
Und den Zweiten Weltkrieg nur
allein aus der Position der Nazis erzählt.
Jetzt hast du ja quasi damit bereits
eine Einstellung.
Na klar, aber generell ist es ja auch so, dass du das ja
immer im Geschichtsunterricht hast.
Wenn ich mal so vergleiche,
Geschichtsunterricht in den USA, den ich ein paar Jahre mit hatte,
und Geschichtsunterricht in Deutschland.
Du hast halt immer einen Fokus auf
die Geschichte des Landes, in dem du dich
befindest. Genau wie wir hier halt
im Geschichtsunterricht, war es wahrscheinlich
so Antike,
dann ein bisschen später so ein paar
Kleinigkeiten und dann gefühlt
8. Klasse bis Abitur war
die Zweite Weltkriege. So habe ich es
zumindest in Erinnerung. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Realität
entsprechend, aber
so habe ich es zumindest in Erinnerung.
Und so Sachen wie die, die halt irgendwo
anders passiert sind, sie wurden halt maximal
ganz kurz angesprochen. Ich glaube sowas wie
amerikanische Unabhängigkeit hatten wir hier im Geschichtsunterricht
gar nicht. Und
in den USA quasi nur.
Und Boston Tea Party natürlich dort.
Du machst halt immer lokale...
Ja, aber ich habe halt keine Ahnung,
was so in Asien passiert.
Das muss ich mir selber irgendwie mal einschauen.
Keine Ahnung, was hier in Kampocha passiert ist.
Es muss natürlich auch gestehen,
dass man nur Betriebszeit für den Unterricht.
Natürlich, ganz klar.
Aber es ist sowas von
sehr punktuell, geografisch geprägt.
Es ist ja nicht mal so
ein ganz kurzer Abriss, sondern so gar nicht international,
finde ich.
Du hast schon irgendwie, ich möchte behaupten,
deutschen Geschichtsunterricht immer noch
einen europäischen Aspekt gab.
Ja, du hast einen sehr zentralen europäischen Fokus, das stimmt.
Mit den Dingen, die so die Ursachen für den Zweiten Weltkrieg
sind und die folgen. Aber es ist halt
alles irgendwo daran orientiert.
Ich meine, ich verstehe es ja auch,
aber gleichzeitig, es schüttelt mich einfach ein bisschen persönlich.
Habe mich damals gestört zumindest.
Mittlerweile ist es mir ein bisschen egal.
Oh Gott.
Nimm das mal bitte auf, was du
gerade gemacht hast und ersetz dieses Geräusch.
Ich habe ja auch
den tollsten Sound mittlerweile,
als macOS Fehler geräumt.
Das krieg ich mich schon wieder aufgenommen.
Ah, ich find's so geil.
Ich muss mir dieses komische Gänse-Spiel mal runterleihen.
Ah, das ist so gut.
Ich stelle mir jetzt hier
Donald Disturb-Modos an.
Ich kloppe mal in die Shownotes
ein Befehl
für den Honk
auf macOS. Da müsst ihr bloß noch in die
Systemeinstellung gehen und unter Töne
das Honk auswählen.
Dann könnt ihr das
da auch mit haben.
Da spielen ja sehr viele Leute irgendwie als Gans.
Ja, das ist so witzig.
Aber es ist ja auch ein Spiel des Jahres.
Hoffentlich wird es das.
Kannst du mal einen Link zu dem Spiel in die Show Notes machen?
Ich habe auch heute erst von dir erfahren,
wo dieses Meme überhaupt erst herkommt.
Untitled Goose Game.
Es ist wirklich ein großartiges Spiel.
Unter anderem mit produziert von Panic.
Das sind die Leute, die auch...
Also generell so eine macOS-Entwicklerbude seit Jahrzehnten,
ich will fast Plura-Jahrzehnten sagen,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie lange es die gibt,
aber mindestens ein Jahrzehnt.
Die sind bekannt für...
2009, das ist jetzt nicht so...
Joa, ich weiß, sicherlich schon länger.
Damals ist es zwar noch nicht Mac OS, aber egal.
Die haben unter anderem Trends mit diesen
SFTP und anderen Sachen klein.
Wie ist Mac OS vorher?
OSX, OS10.
Achso, stimmt, das siehst du ja.
Und davon nochmal anders.
Jedenfalls, und die haben auch Firewatch mit
produziert und die haben mittlerweile
und demnächst bringen die doch so ein eigenes
Hardware-Spielding raus mit dieser Kurbel
an der Seite. Ach du Scheiße.
Das ist aber super witzig. Warte,
Warte, das fand ich cool.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es vorbestellt habe
oder einfach nur haben wollte.
Genau, Playdate, Coming 2020.
So hieß dieses Ding aus.
Die machen sehr gerne
sehr große Webseiten.
Oh ja.
Sieht aus wie so ein Gameboy,
aber hat eine kleine Kurbel an der Seite.
Und diese Kurbel kannst du halt
drehen.
Ist eine Kurbel.
Und Spiele hast du halt drauf ausgelegt.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich ein Bedienungsmittel für das Spiel.
Du hast dir so ein bisschen Spiel, wo du die Zeit vor und zurück
kurbeln kannst.
Die haben halt einfach Spaß.
Die produzieren von dem Ding auch, glaube ich, nur eine Reihe von
so und so viel
Geräten und die wollten einfach mal Spaß
haben. Und ich wäre bestimmt witzig, bei Panic
zu arbeiten. Ich glaube, den Link mal mit
in die Show nutzt.
Ja, ich würde
auch gerne in einer Forschungsabteilung von irgendeiner Firma
arbeiten. Das macht bestimmt viel zu.
Ich hatte, das war
zu WWDC 2016, habe ich so einen Typen
kennengelernt, der ist in der Forschungsabteilung
bei Dyson tätig.
Witzig. Der hat da auch gesagt,
ja, wir haben hier unser selbstfahrende Auto, warte mal,
ihr seid doch Staubsaugerhersteller.
Ja, ja, wir machen alles.
Er hat gerade davon, okay, cool.
Geil.
Kann man bestimmt Spaß mit haben,
wenn das Budget passend ist.
Ja, cooles Gerät.
Obwohl ich mir vorstellen könnte, wenn er in der Straßenbahn
sitzt und dann an diesem Ding
Rummelei hast, guck uns, also ich weiß,
dass ich irgendwie in der Straßenbahn mal hinter zwei
so achtjährigen stand, die
auf einem Game Boy Touch,
war das Game Boy Touch?
Welche Game Boy waren das, wo du so
einen Stift dazu hattest? Ach, dieser DS.
Der DS, auf DS.
Mit dem Stift rumgewischt haben,
wie blöde. Da war das
Display unten schon stumpf.
Ja, das sind so Spiele gewesen, wo du halt wirklich denkst,
die Hardware überlebt das doch nicht und tut sie auch nicht.
Das sieht man in den Dingen, ja.
Ja, bring das Spiel ruhig raus, dann kaufen die Leute
halb von drei Wochen im nächsten. Clever eigentlich.
Ist es nicht bei
iOS nicht sogar verboten,
dass du irgendwie Hardware, die dich dazu
ermutigt,
anregt, dein Gerät kaputt zu machen?
Software, die dich dazu ermutigt, dein Gerät kaputt zu machen?
So wie diese iDrone, diese App,
wo du deine Hand in die Luft wirfst und das
irgendwann Foto machst und es aussieht wie so ein Drohnen-Selfie.
Das stelle ich mir mal geil vor.
Das ist bestimmt noch geiler mit dem neuen
iPhone 11 Plus,
wo du diesen Extrem-Weitwinkel hast.
Ja, sicherlich.
Weil mit dem Extremweitwinkel brauchst du ja weniger Fotos
auf einmal, um irgendwie wirklich eine Kugel zusammen
zu stitchen funktionieren.
Ach, du meinst ja immer, dass du gleich so viele Fotos machen.
Ja, wenn du einen Spin hast,
immer wenn du es hochwirfst.
Das kannst du ja eigentlich nicht wirklich vermeiden.
Es nimmt ziemlich voraussagbar auch immer dieselbe Flugkurve an.
Was?
Da gibt es so ein Veritasium-Video.
Wenn du ein Objekt hast,
was eine Form von einem Telefon
oder einer Schokoladentafel hat,
dann kannst du es ja um drei Achsen drehen,
XYZ. Das kannst du jedes Objekt, ja.
Aber wenn du
dein Telefon nimmst und in die Luft
wirfst und jetzt, sagen wir mal, um die
Z-Achse, also das, was aus dem Display rauskommt,
dann kannst du das,
nimmt das eine stabile Drehung ein, das geht.
Und du kannst es
um die
Y-Achse drehen, also das, was einmal
oben durchgeht. Das
dreht sich dann auch gerade, wenn du es so an der Seite nimmst und drehst.
Wenn du es allerdings versuchst, um die, was bleibt
jetzt noch übrig, um die...
Um die
X-Achse zu drehen.
Also wenn du jetzt dein Telefon wirklich so
nimmst, unten anfasst
und versuchst, so einen Flip zu machen,
dann macht es dabei immer noch
einen Umschlag über die anderen Achsen.
Huch, okay.
Show Notes. Veritasium
Video. Das würde ich doch auch mal sehen.
Und dementsprechend
kannst du, glaube ich, schon relativ gut vorausahnen,
was für eine Flugkurve dein Telefon einnehmen
wird, wenn du es hochwirfst.
Und wenn das eine Kamera mit einem entsprechend kurzen Auslöse und einem großen Blickwinkel hat,
dann kannst du wahrscheinlich auf einem gewissen Punkt, wenn du es gut genug drehst,
mit ein paar Fotos bereits eine...
Es wäre echt witzig, wenn du mit so einem Schlip des Handys und einem guten Fang gleich hier wirklich eine 360-Grad-Aufnahme hättest.
Ja? Also ich überlege bloß, weil es gibt ja diese wirklichen 360-Grad-Kameras
und die sehen eigentlich bloß aus wie eine Fernbedienung.
Die haben auch bloß zwei Kameras.
Ja, ja, zwei Weitwinkel auf beiden Seiten und die machen einfach große...
Bildungstitch nicht zusammen. Kennst du die Videos von
Corridor Crew?
Nee. Corridor Crew ist so ein YouTube-Channel,
das sind einfach so ein paar, das ist ein
Filmstudio, das ist es nicht, aber es ist
so ein Visual Effects
Studio aus Los Angeles.
Die haben ziemlich gut einen YouTube-Channel, den
schau ich in letzter Zeit immer mal.
Die haben vor allem so Videos
VFX Artists
VFX
Artists React. Und dann sitzen
sie einfach auf dem Sofa und schauen sich irgendwelche Visual Effects
auf Filmen. Ich glaube, das hast du schon mal geschickt gehabt.
Genau, das gibt es noch mit Stuntman-React,
weil die einfach Leute kennen und dann laden sie
Stuntman ein und die reagieren dann und dann.
Und die machen aber auch so Spaß-Videos,
wo sie einfach eine 360-Grad-Kamera
vorne auf einen Pfeil
klemmen und den Pfeil dann
mit dem Bogen einmal durch den Park schießen.
Das würde ich gerne mit einer VR-Brille einmal anschauen.
Und das haben sie sich mit einer VR-Brille angenommen.
Oh, wie cool.
Du fliegst und das wird dann stabilisiert, die Kamera kann sich drehen,
wie sie will, und dann kannst du einfach den Horizont
stabilisieren und dann kannst du
dich in diesem fliegenden Pfeil in jede Richtung
Wie cool ist das denn?
Ich wollte mir ja echt mal eine VR-Brille kaufen.
Wenn irgendwer eine gute Empfehlung hat für irgendwas,
was ich halt so versatile auch für solchen Bullshit
nehmen kann. Ich will mal was haben.
Und dann mit so einer Drohne,
mit einer VR-Brille durch die Luft fliegen.
Also es gibt so eine coole neue Drohne, die will ich auch noch kaufen.
Also schaut dir mal Corridor Crew
den YouTube-Channel an. Ich packe mal in die Shownotes.
Die
machen eigentlich
glaube ich lauter Zeugs, was dir gefallen könnte.
Die haben auch dieses
Boston Dynamics Fake Video gemacht.
Von denen ist das.
Genau.
Das ist
einfach jetzt hier
in unserem Showdown Bucket
jetzt mit drin.
Nice.
Genau.
So, weil wir ja schon nicht mehr über Go reden dürfen,
dürfen wir noch über funktionale Programmierung reden?
Du hast dir irgendwas für einen Verlinken gehabt.
Ja, wir hatten vorhin über C und Objective-C
und wie es als ist geredet
und ich habe nördlich mal wieder einen Talk gehört
oder einen Vortrag von
irgendeiner LISP-Konferenz oder sowas
sogar.
Kommt einfach in die Show-Notes rein.
Das ist der Vortrag von,
habe ich auch schon wieder vergessen, der heißt einfach
Why isn't functional programming the norm?
Okay, interessant.
Und der gibt so ein bisschen noch eine Geschichte von
warum sind
die Sprachen heute alle, wie sie sind.
Es ist vornehmlich, weil
irgendwann mal jemand
C gemacht hat und
C war bereits eine Verschlichtung gegenüber,
das war vorher Allgäu oder
Kobol.
Eine davon war bereits funktionaler als C.
Da gibt es einen relativ
guten, das habe ich glaube ich in der letzten Folge erwähnt.
Das hast du auch beim Mittagessen
erwähnt. Kevin Henley Vortrag.
Zumindest
das Problem ist dann, gab es Objective-C
und C++ ja quasi fast zeitgleich,
die einfach bloß
C mit Klassen waren, weil
irgendwie jemand gedacht hatte,
Ah ja, genau. Es ging um Object-Oriented Programming.
Und was ist an Object-Oriented Programming geil?
Na, du hast Klassen, die kombinieren Daten und Verhalten und die können voneinander erben.
Das hat sich irgendjemand für die Sprache, habe ich vergessen, kommt in einem Vortrag vor, ausgedacht.
Der hat halt sein objektorientiert Paradigma damit beschrieben.
Und das haben dann Leute für zum Beispiel Objective-C aufgenommen oder für C mit Klassen, was dann zu C++ wurde.
Und dann ein, zwei Jahre später sagt der ursprüngliche Typ, ja, eigentlich habe ich nicht das mit Object-Orientierung gemeint.
Mit Object-Orientierung habe ich eigentlich gemeint, dass du Objekte hast, Instanzen hast, die sich Nachrichten hin- und herschicken können, Message-Passing, was du bei Objective-C ja auch irgendwie hast.
Irgendwie, das ist so das Kernkonzept.
Genau, aber dass du Klassen hast, die Funktionen implementieren, die von anderen Klassen erben und dann diese Funktionalität überschreiben oder mitvererben oder genau dieses Problem von Inheritance, was du bei C++, Java hast oder nicht weißt, benutze ich jetzt die Funktion von der Klasse oder von der Parent-Klasse.
Das ist so das Hauptproblem.
Und das gehört eigentlich für denjenigen,
der den Begriff Object-Oriented ursprünglich gecoint hat,
nicht wirklich mit dazu.
Witzigerweise.
Und du siehst ja, wir reden zum 5000. Mal in diesem Podcast darüber,
dass diese Art und Weise von Objektorientierung
hier bereits wieder verschwindet.
Go, Swift, Rust haben kein Konzept von Vererbung,
nicht wirklich, so wie ich das verstehe.
Swift sehr wohl, doch schon.
Ja, bei Swift hast du keine Vererbung.
Es ist nicht, ich würde sagen,
das ist ein Swifty-Ansatz mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Aber es ist sehr wohl
in Kernsklima.
Bei Go und Rust
war das Konzept, dass du
Objekte hast, denen du Methoden
zuordnen kannst, aber
die können nicht voneinander erben.
Das heißt, du weißt eigentlich immer ziemlich genau,
wessen Methoden du aufrufst,
wenn du eine Objektinstanz in der Hand hast.
Ja, in Zwift obfus gehörst du das durch Protokolle
im Fotos halt dann sehr
unklar.
Anyway, das war jetzt eine ziemlich stammliche
Zusammenfassung. Ich gebe den
Vortrag Why Isn't Functional Programming
the Norm? Mal mit ins Protokoll.
Der ist auch nicht sonderlich lang.
Klingt auf jeden Fall spannend.
Fand ich ziemlich gut. Genau.
Wir haben
gesagt, wir wollten einen kurzen machen. Wir sind
jetzt bei knapp über einer Stunde.
Also wahrscheinlich für die Hörer, die jetzt
auf die Uhr gucken, sind wir noch nicht bei einer Stunde,
weil wir immer ein bisschen früher aufnehmen.
Weil wir immer ein bisschen früher
die Aufnahme starten.
Wollen wir
weiter über PIX reden?
ein Ding hier habe ich noch,
weil ich es ein witziges Projekt fand.
Das Ding heißt
Schgit oder S-H-Git.
Ich vermute immer Schgit.
Ist ein witziges Tool,
das jemand gebastelt hat,
wie so viele Tools.
Und zwar geht es darum,
dass DevSecOps,
The Art of Embedding Security into the Software Development Lifecycle,
ein Ding ist, was viele Leute
als Third Vector wirklich
oft underestimaten.
wie er hier schreibt.
Und einfach mal
auf API-Keys mitkommitten,
irgendwelche Logs mitkommitten, Dinge,
alles mögliche an Dingen, die eigentlich
nicht mit in dem repo liegen sollten.
Ich habe die Seite jetzt einfach mal aufgemacht und der lädt jetzt
irgendwie weitere Einträge in dieser
Tabelle nach. Was passiert hier?
Diese Seite, die beobachtet Recent Commits
auf GitHub,
GitLab und ich glaube Public Bitbucket.
Also Public GitLab, Public Bitbucket
und GitHub.
Und schaut einfach nach, wenn das keine Forks sind,
wenn das irgendwie eine benötigte Menge an Stars hat,
das Webbo oder so, oder auch nicht, dann
schaut es da in die Commit-Diffs rein, weil du kriegst ja
von GitHub oder von anderen auch einen gewissen Stream
an neuen Commits und schaut einfach mal rein, es matcht hier
irgendwas auf irgendwelche API-Keys
oder auf irgendwelche Log-Files oder
auf Private-Keys
oder auf SQLite-Databys-Files
und listet die halt so lang,
weil du diese Seite öffnest, einfach der Reihe nach auf. Ich hab die Seite
jetzt offen, seitdem wir aufnehmen. Ich hab hier
würde ich grob schätzen 150 Einträge
von diversen
KDE Wallet Manager Database.
What?
Vieles ist natürlich hier.
KeyPass, Password Manager.
Potential Private Key sehe ich hier viele,
Config-PAPs, Log-Dateien,
diverse Django-Configuration,
falls immer so ein Klassiker.
Vieles davon bringt ja nichts,
aber es sind auch ziemlich viele AWS
oder Google-API-Keys dabei.
Was holt halt ich da an?
Ich glaube, AWS ist sogar so clever,
die machen das auch, ich glaube,
das beschreibt er auch in seinem Podcast,
in seinem Blogpost.
AWS schaut die ganze Zeit,
was so Commits auf GitHub sind
und wenn sie da AWS-Keys sehen,
dann invalidieren sie die sofort.
Glaube ich. Ich meine, AWS macht das.
Was ja auch clever ist, aber ist natürlich
ein krasser Aufwand, den die dafür betreiben.
Nee, das ist aber auch super, weil es hat uns auch schon
mal den Arsch gerettet. Das hat ein Student bei uns
Credentials für einen Third-Party-Service
eingecheckt.
Und wir haben seitdem immer noch kein neues Passwort
dafür gekriegt, weil die das gemerkt haben
und gesagt haben, das Passwort
ist jetzt hier auf GitHub aufgetaucht,
wir machen das mal aus.
Könnt ihr euch ein Ticket machen, um das wieder aufzumachen?
Cool. Aber ey, immerhin haben sie es halt gemerkt.
Das ist schon echt was wert.
Du kriegst ja auch von GitHub jetzt teilweise schon relativ
gute Hinweise. Also du kriegst irgendwie von
Dependabot, was deren
eingebauter Renovate-Bot ist quasi.
Den kannst du aktivieren.
Aber von dem kriegst du jetzt auch Hinweise.
Da sind jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen zwei
Request auf Repos aufgegangen, die eigentlich schon lange
tot sind, wo ich mit darauf hänge.
Wo festgestellt wurde, die Dependency,
da hast du eine Vulnerability drin.
Ich zieh das mal für dich hoch.
Das bauen sie auch mal weiter aus.
die supported Sprachen.
Das ist auch eigentlich genau das, was man von so einem Service
möchte, wenn der genügend
Integration, also sowas wie GitHub, wenn es genügend Integration mit
dem Paketmanagern hat oder bereits
genügend Integration mit anderen Services,
die dir sagen können, da ist
normalerweise eine Konfig-Datei, die nicht eingecheckt
werden sollte, dann ist es geil, wenn es dir das
sagt. Ja, was ich übrigens sehr clever finde
an dem Dependent Bot, ist, dass sie die
CVIs, die dir verlinkt sind,
nicht offen beschreiben, sondern bloß die Dependent in den PR hochziehen,
damit du nicht explizit einfach nur rumgehen kannst
und schauen kannst, ah, da hat der Pendler bei uns aufgemacht.
Der PR ist noch nicht gemützt, lass das mal schnell abusen.
Explicit machen
sie das nur für den Projekt-Owner
offensichtlich, was da die
gefixten CVEs sind. Das ist schon
auf jeden Fall... Finde ich gut mitgedacht, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich meine, gut, ich glaube, das wäre da relativ
schnell aufgefallen, wenn du gesagt hast, ja übrigens,
das hier ist offen für diesen Angriffsvektor.
Ist halt blöd. Ach so?
Gut zu wissen. Ach so?
Du wirst so richtig bestraft dafür,
Open Source zu machen.
Ja, das wäre das Schlimmste, was passieren könnte,
dass die Leute dann sagen, auf GitHub stelle ich das nicht nochmal.
Das sieht ja jeder gleich, wo es
vulnerable ist.
Lass mal so wirklich so den Pixie übergehen, guter Hinweis.
Und zwar habe ich
ein witziges Projekt entdeckt,
das heißt Longest Coco.
Das ist kein Projekt, sondern eigentlich nur
ein GitHub-Repo,
was wieder in der Readme was beschreibt.
Und zwar geht es darum,
dass Symbol Names in
Coco, also dem Apple
System Framework, gut, wie beschreibt man Coco?
habe ich wahrscheinlich schon verkackt,
dass mit dem Interface, wenn du Apps
für Apple-Plattformen schreibst,
wo du UI-Krams drin liegst,
diverse System-Libraries und APIs und alles mögliche,
dass das bekannt dafür ist,
sehr deskriptive und verbose Namen zu haben.
Und da ist jemand mal durchgegangen,
hat im iPhone OS, glaube ich,
hier und auch Mac OS hier unten
mal die längsten Namen rausgesucht.
Das ist das Längste, was ich hier gerade finden kann.
Ein Inam Constant Name,
KCM Buffer Queue Trigger
when duration becomes greater than or equal to
and buffer count becomes greater than.
Das ist ja noch langweilig, irgendwas was witziger klingt,
wie zum Beispiel ein
das ist wahrscheinlich Intent Framework aus SiriKit
in get available restaurant reservation booking
defaults Intent Handling.
Das hat 64 Zeichen ein.
Ich finde das sick.
Erinnert mich aber gerade an
so ein
Tweet von, na wie heißt er?
Armin Ronacher
auf Twitter. Mitsuhiko oder so?
Der Typ, der, wenn ich
mich jetzt gerade nicht täusche, Flask mitentwickelt.
Ach so? Wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Auf jeden Fall irgendwas Populäres, Python-artiges.
Ich glaube, es ist Flask. Muss ich passen.
Der arbeitet bei Sentry.
Sentry ist ja so eine Crash-Reporting-Plattform.
Eigentlich auch eine echt schicke Plattform.
Sentry hat jetzt auch, da wollte ich vorhin drüber reden,
als ich erwähnt habe, die Seite hat aber
eine schöne animierte Frontpage.
Sentry hatte eigentlich bis vor kurzem
eine ziemlich geile animierte Frontpage,
wo du einen Typ in so einem dunklen Raum an einem Bildschirm
stehen siehst, mit einem Fenster dahinter,
vielleicht gibt es das noch in irgendeinem Archiv,
Fenster dahinter, Stadt, und dann siehst du kurz,
wie neben seinem Laptop das Display
von dem Telefon plötzlich so aufblinkt
und plötzlich hinter ihm in der Stadt komplett überall das Licht ausgeht.
Das war eine wunderschöne Seite.
Das war auch sehr reptil.
Jetzt haben sie ein anderes Artwork
auf der Startseite, was aber auch ziemlich schick ist.
Müssen wir mal jetzt bei Barcraft schauen.
Aber klingt schick. Jedenfalls hat er mal getweetet,
dass sie bei Sentry
ein Problem hatten, und zwar konnten sie
für einen Kunden von Sentry nicht die
Symbole in seinem Crashlog auflösen,
weil dem seine Funktionsname
in diesem C++-Projekt,
das er hatte, mehr als 64.000
Zeichen lang war.
64.000
Zeichen.
Alter.
Ich meine, logischerweise ist das irgendwie ein generierter
Template-Code, aber
das fand ich schon geil.
Ja, Code-Generation for the win,
würde ich sagen. Auf jeden Fall.
Was hast du noch als Pick?
Ja, ein bisschen um meine Stars auch zu organisieren,
gibt es Stargast.
Und das ist einfach ein Skript, was ich,
wenn du dem dein GitHub,
wenn du dem ein GitHub-Access-Token gibst,
so eine awesome Webseite aus deinen Stars generiert.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Eine awesome Webseite aus deinen Stars generiert?
Ja, das ist, warte mal, ich mache die Seite endlich mal auf.
Ja, und zwar heißt es hier
Creating your own awesome list of GitHub-Stars.
ich habe
das selber auch wie gesagt noch nicht gemacht, aber
es wäre nicht mal witzig, wenn wir
unsere eigenen GitHub-Awesome-Seiten
für akronomisierbar erzeugen,
wo wir unsere beiden Stars zusammenschmeißen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so gut skaliert,
ich habe irgendwie mittlerweile über
2000 Stars oder Sachen gestartet,
aber mit dem Ding hier
kannst du dir dann irgendwie, wenn du
eine Übersicht haben möchtest...
Ich weiß eh nicht, was ich gestartet habe, manchmal suche ich einfach nur irgendein Projekt für irgendwas,
öffne einfach meine Stars und gebe irgendwelche
Keywords ein. 1387
Projekte habe ich gestartet.
Das ist mittlerweile
sowas von nutzlos.
Ja.
Das würde ich eh nicht machen.
Egal, aber finde ich witzig.
Ach, der kopiert das hier nach Sprachen
und
okay.
Und hat zumindest diese Skripsen-Diräumung.
Da habe ich zumindest eine Seite, wo ich dann besser
Command-F'n kann. Genau.
Ich meine, das ist eigentlich
angenehmer, finde ich.
sehr hilfreich, dass ihr überall statisch den Star-Account
daneben schreibt. Schöner finde ich diese
Astral-App. Stimmt, das gab es auch mal.
Die haben wir auch schon
mal gestarrt gehabt.
Gepickt, gepickt.
Astral-App.
Nehmt lieber Astral-App.
Da brauchst du auch kein eigenes
Skript ausführen. Da gehst du einfach
hin, gibst dem mal kurz Zugriff auf deinen
GitHub-Account.
Zumindest die Sachen, die er dir da
erlaubt. Und dann hast du eine schöne Auflistung nach
Sprachen. Und dann siehst du,
ich zum Beispiel, ich habe
491 Rust-Stars, dann
das zweite größte ist dann
109 JavaScript-Stars und
56 C++-Stars.
Witzig, in welchen Gefilden du dich so umtreibst.
Ich habe aber auch zwei Crystal-Stars,
zwei Elixier-Stars.
Crystal und Elixier sind beides toll.
Was zum Geil, ich habe gestartet,
was in Action-Script ist.
Dann kann ich hier draufklicken und dann kommt,
das lädt ein bisschen langsam, no results.
Ja, klappt ja gut.
Klappt ausgezeichnet, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Nevermind, ich habe doch keine
Notebook gibt es auch?
Ja, ich habe einen, das ist Slack-Sets von dir
Ah, okay
Nice, finde ich cool
Ich habe hier noch was gestartet
Es heißt Diff So Fancy
Das ist ein Git Differ
Quasi ein kleines Skript
Was ist denn das geschrieben?
Da ist es in Perl geschrieben
Das ziehe ich mal als
ein Skript in Betracht
Aua
Ah, jetzt macht ihr einfach deine GitHub-Skripts,
deine Git-Diffs auf der Konsole hübscher.
Genau.
Und zwar legst du das einfach in deiner Git-Config als Differ an.
Ah, nice.
Und von dann an ist dein Git-Diff-Output so viel besser lesbar,
weil er das nicht einfach, also der hat bessere Fonts,
der markiert die Bereiche, die geänderten.
Das kannst du mit der Git-Einstellung natürlich auch machen.
Da fragst du dich jetzt als erstes, okay, das ist cool.
Das sieht man auch dem Screenshot sofort an, was es macht.
Aber was benutzt du produktiv als Git-Div-Tool?
Ich benutze für alles eine GUI namens Fork.
Fork ist die beste App meiner Meinung nach dazu.
Und Git auf der Konsole ist auch ein tolles Tool.
Nutze ich auch gerne manchmal.
Aber mein Workflow ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht wieso,
aber ich habe mich sehr, sehr, sehr daran gewöhnt,
interaktiv zu stagen und nie alles zu stagen und zu committen,
was ich gerade so als DIVs im Working-Tree habe.
Das mache ich einfach generell nie.
Und deswegen bin ich echt darauf angewiesen,
also wirklich live zu sehen,
den Diff und bestenfalls im Diff
direkt Selections machen zu können.
Und interaktives Stagen
mit Git auf der Command Line ist so unglaublich.
Also es geht.
Das habe ich heute erst wieder gemacht.
Git-Add-Up.
Git was?
Was macht UP?
Ich habe irgendwas für ein Interactive mal.
Es gibt Interactive, da kannst du dir dann auswählen,
ob du die Datei überhaupt einchecken willst mit U.
sagst du, checke nur
Sachen ein, die bereits getrackt werden,
also nicht neue Dateien.
Und P macht Patch und dann
fragt er dich bei jeder Datei, möchtest du das
einchecken und dann kannst du die einzelnen Bereiche noch
splitten. Ja, aber das ist so mühsam mit dieser
20 Zeichen gegeben,
die Commands, die du nutzen kannst.
Ja, toll, das ist absolut unbedienbar.
Und in
diversen GUIs, ob du jetzt sowas auf
macOS-spezifisch, ob du so wie Tower oder
SourceTree oder Fork, was das beste
neue Tool dafür ist. Ah, das ist sogar umsonst.
Ja, es ist umsonst. Es ist Windows und Mac.
Nice. Es ist ein echt
schickes Tool. Und da sehe ich halt den ganzen
Diff, ich kann entweder ganze
wie nennt man Bereiche,
da gibt es so einen Begriff für einen.
Ja.
Das da.
Nicht Chunk, sondern...
Sind sie sogar Chunk?
Mal vor und aufmachen, dann sehe ich sie schon.
Schön, dass in dem Screenshot
hier Yahuda Cuts vorkommt.
Hat der da eventuell dran mitgebaut?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht.
aber ich kann halt auch einfach hier
dragen mit der Maus, um einzelne Zeilenbereiche
zu markieren und sagen, ich möchte die hier stagen
oder ich möchte die einfach diskarten
und es ist sehr einfach durch Tasten
Das heißt, es hat einen Code Viewer mit eingebaut
Es hat einen Code Viewer eingebaut, sieht so hier aus, ich kann es ja mal kurz zeigen
so sieht aus, ich kann hier einfach hier
durchscrollen, ich kann hier Bereiche markieren, sagen
ich möchte direkt das stagen oder diskarten
und das alles dann, ich bediene das Ding
hauptsächlich durch das Zerturkürzel und es hat auch
ein paar sehr tolle Features, zum Beispiel wenn du
den Brand-Track sitzt und du hast gerade Dirty Changes
drin, dann sagt sie so,
möchtest du die andere GUIs oder
Git selber machen, du musst dir erstmal committen.
Aber Fork gibt dir zusätzlich noch die Option, ja warte mal,
willst du vielleicht die stashen
und nach dem Switch reapplyen, weil
das ist, was ich meistens haben möchte.
Und das ist einfach das erste Programm,
was das kann.
Ich finde Fork super toll.
Das ist mein absolutes Lieblingsprogramm
geworden, was Git angeht.
Und ich nutze eigentlich nur noch das.
Nice. Das ist toll.
git-fork.com
Also ich habe mich selber dabei erwischt,
wie ich zum Beispiel zum Organisieren
von Branches oder
zum Code-Reviewen GitLens
mehr und mehr verwende.
GitLens war das VS Code Plugin, oder?
Das ist ein VS Code Plugin und du hast dann
auf der linken Seite, es sieht ähnlich aus wie hier,
aber es ist direkt in deinem VS Code drin,
so eine Liste, Auflistung von allen Remotes
und den Branches, die da drin liegen. Du hast dann zum Beispiel auch
deine lokalen Branches und dann kannst du einfach
einen Branch aufklicken, ohne den ausgecheckt
zu haben. Und dann siehst du die in einer
Ordnerstruktur, die Dateien, die da drin sind.
Und kannst die anklicken, siehst die Diffs da drin.
Diffio und einchecken
ist auch in VS Code schon ziemlich angenehm. Also für
Sachen auf Arbeit nehme ich eigentlich nur noch das.
Das ist cool. Aber auch sowas ja wie
ich wechsle mal den Branch, aber nehme irgendeine
Datei mit. Das mache ich auf der Konsole
mal schnell, da bin ich eigentlich da.
Das habe ich so im Rückenmarkt drin.
Ich finde es eigentlich auch ganz cool, dass Xcode da jetzt immer weiter geht
und weiteren Support für
Source Control mit einbaut. Ich nutze Xcode eigentlich nicht,
für Source Control, also ich committe nicht mit Xcode, ich
pushe Pulle nicht mit Xcode, ich
Webase nicht mit Xcode, wer weiß, ob das kann.
Aber was ich toll finde, ist das
Git-Gatter in Xcode, weil das halt auch
so weit geht und sagt, hier war diese Änderung
übrigens, das ist gleich direkt ein roter Balken dran,
wenn du die so committest, dann wird das ein Konflikt.
Und das finde ich einfach geil, wenn das im Editor
direkt mit drinsteht, weil Xcode einfach,
also fast alles an Code, was ich aktuell schreibe, ist in Xcode.
Und das finde ich
einfach ein nettes Feature, genauso wie es halt
grau markiert, Dinge, die committed sind,
aber noch nicht gepurscht, oder?
glaube. Aber auf jeden Fall markiert
das irgendwie. Aber das finde ich
einfach ein schönes Feature für den Editor. Das gefällt mir.
Nicht schlecht. Hat Xcode
mittlerweile wieder Win-Bindings? Nee.
Das war
den Raider-Thread
habe ich mir auch durchgelesen.
Da gab es viele Kommentare, auch sehr viele
interne Kommentare.
Das wäre toll. Also noch nicht.
Nee.
Vielleicht, wenn irgendwann die Plugin-Infrastruktur
wieder ausgebaut wird, dann
wäre das ja mal vielleicht was, was vielleicht
wieder aufleben könnte. Das war auf jeden Fall schick.
Nicht, dass ich es hart nutzen würde,
aber an manchen Stellen,
manchmal geht es doch schneller von der Hand.
Obwohl macOS
finde ich auch echt eine sehr robuste
Text-Editor-Keybinding-
Infrastruktur,
keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das denn, hat.
macOS ist da echt
angenehm, was
die Tastaturkürzler angeht, um in Text
zu navigieren, systemweit.
es gibt sogar irgendwie einen Yank-Tastaturkürzel
im System, das habe ich vor kurzem erst gelernt
fand ich sehr interessant
also es geht quasi nochmal an einem Clipboard vorbei
in einem anderen Buffer
das ist natürlich ganz schlau
das fand ich witzig, dass sowas überhaupt existierte
wie gesagt, seit Ewigkeiten habe ich nicht gewusst
aber das kann man
in Xcode auch, wenn man den System Shortcut
für Space wechseln
von Kontroll-Falltasten
wegnimmt, kann man mit Kontroll-Falltasten
plötzlich in, also es geht nur in Xcode
bei Xcode Keywords
erkennt mit CamelCase, kannst
du durch CamelCase Wörter
durchspringen von Wort zu Wort
und da auch Selections machen. Das finde ich
nett. Das ist ein tolles Feature.
Aber wie gesagt, da musst du den System
Shortcut von Control-File-Tasten
entfernen, sonst wechselst du durch Spaces.
Witzig.
Okay, hast du noch einen GitHub-Star?
Ja, und zwar...
Ja, und zwar, ich spiele in der letzten Zeit ein bisschen
mit Web-Audio rum und heute war was auf
muss, was ich sonst hätte selber bauen müssen.
Ich bin froh, dass ich es nicht selber bauen muss.
Und das heißt Quiet.js.
Und Quiet.js macht folgendes, das nimmt
Text
oder
auch Bilder, habe ich hier gesehen,
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, und
transmittet die als entweder
Ultraschall oder als
hörbarer Schall.
Und es ist einfach eine durchgehende Webseite,
wo man entweder sagen kann, hier Text eingeben
und dann wird es transmitted.
Oder einfach hier Start Listening.
und dann wird das
angenommen und empfangen.
Ich habe dir da gerade ein Stück Text
geschickt und ich würde dich
bitten, das mal
zu übertragen und mal schauen,
ob wir das anständig empfangen.
Wir sind mal leise. Ich halte mein Mikro hier
nah an den Lautsprecher ran. Wir versuchen gleichzeitig
das auf deinem Rechner zu empfangen. Genau, also ich habe jetzt bei mir
auf den Listening-Knopf gedrückt.
Zusätzlich könnt ihr natürlich auch mal
dann in den Show Notes auf den Link zu
Quiet gehen, Quiet.js.
Aber besser auf dem Rechner. Ich glaube,
man braucht Firefox oder Ad steht hier
zumindest in den... Es geht in Chrome.
Es geht wahrscheinlich einfach in Chrome. Und auf
Start Audible Receiver klicken und
euer Handy ans...
Mach mal Ultrasonic.
Das rechnet auch vorne die Kundenanprobe aus.
Na gut, okay. Dann probier mal Audible.
Ich würde Audible machen. Und haltet euer Handy dann auch mal
getestet. Genau. Und wenn ihr das empfangen
könnt, dann ist in diesem Text ein
Keyword enthalten.
Wenn ihr mir das per
Twitter schickt, dann kriegt ihr einen
akronymisierbarer Sticker.
Okay, ich geh mal hier ganz nah ran,
mal schauen, ob es funktioniert.
Jetzt musst du natürlich bei mir selber
mal den Audible Receiver, nicht den Ultrasonic
Receiver starten.
So, aber du kannst es gerne nochmal machen.
Mach mal, bitte nochmal.
Also meiner hat es nicht empfangen.
Probier das mal bitte mit Ultraschall.
Okay.
So, listening.
Ja, das Setup ist schon ein bisschen empfindlich.
Also wenn ihr das wirklich empfangen habt,
bekommt ihr von mir auf jeden Fall
einen Sticker. Und wenn nicht,
dann schreibt mich einfach an der Karte.
Aber vorhin, als wir im ASCII saßen, hast du darüber
im Ultraschall einfach random
Nachrichten geschickt und die kam bei mir mit einem
Webseite, die erkennt tatsächlich,
wenn was kommt und sagt
dann auch den Packet-Loss mit an.
Und so ein Packet-Loss zwischen 30 und 70 Prozent,
je nach dem Test, den wir gefahren haben, kamen hier wirklich Daten an.
Und ich habe dein Lorem Ipsum halt wirklich hier sehen können bei mir.
Das fand ich schon erstaunlich geil.
Ich glaube, bei dem Setup hängt es ein bisschen sehr davon ab,
wie die Lautsprecher und Mikrofone aufeinander ausgerichtet sind.
Wir haben jetzt hier versucht, gerade was über Laptop-Lautsprecher
auf ca. 60% Lautsperke in ein Mikrofon reinzupipen.
Was wir dann nochmal rumrechnen, sogar bis zu dreimal.
Einmal bei dir, bis es durch Reaper läuft,
dann einmal durch Auphonic und dann nochmal bei
Simplecast. Wenn da wirklich was am Ende bei rumkommt,
Simplecast encodet das.
Simplecast macht nochmal irgendwie Bullshit.
Und wenn da am Ende
wirklich was bei rauskommt, was sich irgendwie dekodieren lässt,
dann wäre das schon mega cool.
Ich kann es nicht glauben, aber das wäre schon irgendwie
geil.
Kriegen wir vielleicht irgendwie die Datei hier nicht
raus, was der an Rauschen erzeugt und können
das einfach in den Podcast hinten dran hängen
oder ersetzen an der Stelle gerade?
Oder hast du jetzt das nächste Bastelprojekt
hochgetragen? Ich könnte eventuell...
Du hast doch Web-Audio-Ahnung.
Kannst du das nicht irgendwie in der Datei streamen?
Ich will das aber auch nicht unnötig machen.
Ja, es geht jetzt bestimmt.
Ob ich es wirklich machen möchte.
Das wird zumindest die Chancen stark erhöhen,
dass das funktioniert am Ende.
Wir machen jetzt immer subliminale Nachrichten
in unseren Podcast-Feeds.
Es wäre doch super witzig, wenn einfach schon die ganze Zeit,
also nicht, dass jetzt jemand pro nachhören würde,
weil es ist natürlich nicht so wink wink
irgendwelche Ultraschallnachrichten
hier in dem Podcast im Bett.
Das hatte ich eigentlich dann fest vor,
als Reveal von
meinem Web-Audio-Talk, den ich
irgendwann demnächst halten würde.
Dass ich die ganze Zeit sage, übrigens nehmt mal
euer Telefon raus und geht mal auf diese Seite
und wenn ihr jetzt auf Empfang drückt, dann bekommt
ihr übrigens gerade diese Nachricht oder sowas.
Aber das ist zumindest
ein ziemlich cooles Projekt, hat natürlich auch
ein Stückchen Web-Assembly
mit eingebaut, weil die ursprüngliche
Library, auf der das basiert, die natürlich
Text in den
Audio-Frequenz-Bereich kodiert,
ist LibFec, also
F-E-C,
die wahrscheinlich in C geschrieben ist, weiß ich nicht genau.
Cooles Teil
und demonstriert mal wieder, wie man,
was man nicht alles mit dem Webbrowser
alles machen kann. Auf jeden Fall,
vor allem generell mit Audio auch.
Also, wenn man das hier noch, wie man früher
irgendwelche Daten, eigentlich einmal abstruse
Datenmengen versucht hat, über Infrarot
zwischen zwei prähistorischen Mobiltelefonen zu versenden.
Und dann, ich schicke jetzt dieses Bild.
Oh shit, das dauert einen Tag.
Ja.
Einzelne Musikdateien per Bluetooth auf dem Schulhof auszuschreiben.
Oh ja, oh ja.
Aber vor allem, das war der uralt Bluetooth damals.
Ich muss wieder hoch.
Die Pause ist vorbei.
Ja, warte noch schnell.
20 Minuten lang, zwei Telefone nebeneinander halten.
Und irgendwie eine MP3-Megabyte MP3 auszusetzen.
MP3 gab es damals schon?
Ja, klar.
Was denkst du dir, wie alt ich bin?
Anyway, es funktioniert
Wenn du nicht dein Alter anspült, dann gibt es ja irgendwelche LPs getauscht
während du auf dem Schulhof
Weißt du, wie du Schallplatten gut gut lecken kannst?
Mit Holzleim
Ah, stimmt, stimmt, aber ich meine, das Video gesehen auf YouTube
Das war so sehr
nicht in
satisfying, also das ist schön eingestrichen
mit Holzleim, am Ende so dieses Abziehen
Das war toll
Wir wollen doch hier keine ASMR-Anspielung machen
Das war visuelles ASMR.
Aber es hat auch dieses geile
Geräusche. Und du hast
quasi in dem Moment die gesamte Schallplatte
einmal gehört. Das war irgendwie immer
ein Teil vorwärts, während du gleichzeitig ein Teil rückwärts
und fünf Spuren parallel gehört hast, aber...
Klappt das so? Ich erinnere mich gerade
an einen...
Na, das war letztens ein Hacker-News-Post.
Von wegen, das Internet-Archive
hat angefangen,
LPs von irgendeiner Bibliothek
in Amerika zu digitalisieren.
Und da war noch ein Bild dabei, wo sie haufenweise Rechner hatte mit so Schallplattenspielern,
die aber digital angeschlossen wurden an den Rechner und dann haben sie die einfach transferiert.
Und dann gab es aber Kommentare, dass die Person noch nie einen Schallplattenspieler gesehen hat,
der einfach ohne Zutun eine ganze Schallplatte am Stück fehlerfrei abspielt.
Und dass es doch viel cooler wäre.
Und dann war es so ein verlinktes Projekt.
Ich ärgere mich gerade sehr, dass ich das nicht schon hier mit ins Pad geschmissen habe.
Der hatte erwähnt ein Projekt,
wo jemand mit einer hochauflösenden Kamera
beziehungsweise auf einem Flatbed-Scanner
LPs gelegt hat und aus diesen
Bildern die Musik rausgerippt hat.
Oh nein.
Das geht nicht.
Eine Schallplatte, da siehst du die Rillen ja.
Ja, aber nee, das geht nicht.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel DPU du brauchst,
dass du das rausziehen kannst.
Das war schon...
Ich such das nochmal raus.
Ich such das mal wieder raus.
Ich weiß, dass es Plattenspieler gibt,
die mit einem Laser die Rillen abscannen.
Theoretisch haben die Schallplatten immer noch,
möchte ich behaupten, eine geringere Datendichte,
also zumindest von den Konturen, als eine CD.
Ja, wo man vielfach ist.
Du siehst die Rillen ja an der CD, siehst du ja nichts.
Ja, aber trotzdem hast du ja,
die Rillen selber haben ja eine analoge Kontur.
Ja, klar.
Und deswegen ist es ein Problem, das digital darzustellen.
Und die kannst du natürlich nur beliebig genau abtasten.
Du hast dann immer,
ist es lossy, der ript davon.
Aber kannst du dir vorstellen, was man eine CD, ich hab auch schon überlegt,
ob man eine CD irgendwann auf dem Flachbett-Scanner
scannen könnte
und die dadurch bootleggt.
Überleg mal, wo wir sind. Du kannst ein hochauflösendes
Foto mit einer normalen
DSLR,
DLSR,
mit einer hochauflösenden Spiegereflexkamera
kannst du
Fotos machen auf eine Entfernung von
Metern
im Zehnerbereich von Personen
und daraus ihre Fingerabdrücke klauen.
Ja, Fingerabdrücke sind aber nicht so fein.
Die Fingerabdrücke sind nicht viel feiner
oder nicht wirklich feiner als eine Schallplatte.
Behaupte ich.
Ne, die sind wesentlich grober als eine Schallplatte.
Ne, ich meine, die sind relativ...
Ich habe jetzt keine Schallplatte vor Augen.
Vielleicht mal eine Schallplatte rausholen.
Bitte, ich will das jetzt hier maximal hilfreich
für unseren Podcast.
Aber ich hätte gerne mal eine Schallplatte in der Hand
und will Rillen mit meinem Finger vergleichen.
Also, was haben wir hier?
Gary Mulligan,
Jack Baker,
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut man dich gerade gehört hat.
Das ist eine
Chad Baker Schallplatte.
Die ich leider momentan
mangels einer anstehenden
Apparatur nicht abspielen kann. Aber wenn ich dir das
jetzt gebe, da siehst du, dass
da Rillen sind. Ja. Okay, ich nehme alles
zurück. Diese Rillen bedeutend feiner, als ich es erwartet hätte.
Ja.
Das geht nicht.
Also ich möchte behaupten, es gibt
garantiert irgendwelche industriellen Flachbett-
Scanner, die eventuell da
rankommen, aber... Wenn du das Licht so
über die Kanten spiegeln lässt, siehst du halt wirklich
schön feine Konturen. Nicht nur die Rillen an sich,
sondern auch Differenzen in den Rillen.
Wenn jemand
eine gute alte Stereoanlage abzugeben hat,
ich würde mich da sehr viel interessieren.
Meine Schwester ist so ein Hipster, die hat sich mal
einen alten DDR-Schallplattenspieler
besorgt und sie besitzt genau
eine Schallplatte, die ich ihr zu Weihnachten
geschenkt habe. Und zwar ein Album
von Rick Ersley, wo unter anderem
immer gar nicht überhaupt drauf ist.
Ich habe mir vor kurzem, meine Eltern haben sich irgendwie nach Jahren mal einen neuen Fernseher und gleichzeitig dann so eine Bose Soundbar gegönnt.
Und da musste ich dann unbedingt helfen, das anzuschließen.
Ich kann euch empfehlen, holt euch keine Samsung Smart TVs.
Es war gruselig, aber meine Eltern wollten das haben.
Und dann haben sie ihre 35 Jahre alten Lautsprecher-Stereo-Boxen rausgeschmissen.
Und ich habe mich natürlich sehr gefreut, die einfach mitzunehmen.
Natürlich.
Die Kabel waren schon so durch, dass ich die nur,
oder waren auch so in dem Wohnzimmer verbaut, dass ich die quasi nur abschneiden
konnte. Das heißt, ich habe die jetzt irgendwie mit
Kabelenden, Kapseln
neu verklemmt und mit Lüsterklemmen
irgendwie, also Goldkabel
Gläubige werden mich verfluchen,
aber ich habe hier gerade hinten...
Goldkabel sind so ein Bullshit.
Anyway, ich habe jetzt diese wunderschönen
alten Boxen da stehen, aber die alte
Stereoanlage, die sie ursprünglich dazu haben,
haben sie schon vor mehreren Jahren weggeworfen
und durch einen Bluetooth,
ne Quatsch, durch einen Blu-Ray-Player ersetzt,
der zufällig auch Musik abspielen kann,
der hat dummerweise keinen Stereo-Ausgang,
sondern der hatte ursprünglich auch dazu
zwei kleinere Hochtöner und einen Subwoofer,
so einen Tieftöner, stehen.
Das hat jetzt für mich,
weil ich nur den jetzt auch dazu habe,
leider die Konsequenz,
dass ich den Subwoofer mit anschließen muss,
weil die beiden Stereo-Links-Rechts-Ausgänge
die tiefen Frequenzen nicht mit übertragen.
Und den nur an den dritten, an den
Tieftönern mit übertragen.
Deswegen suche ich jetzt gerade zur absoluten
Befriedigung meiner
auditiven Neigung
einfach nur so eine
alte klassische Stereoanlage.
Schau immer mal bei Ebay Kleinerzeigen,
aber dann gibt es ja diese riesen Tower,
muss vielleicht auch nicht sein, aber irgendwie einfach so
ein oller Mixer, wo du noch
über Cinch irgendwie
noch einen alten CD-Player anschließen kannst,
meinetwegen, und dann einfach nur zwei
Stereo ausgehen.
Was ganz einfaches.
Schinch ist auch ein toller Stecker gewesen.
Naja, ist ja immer noch überall dran, fast.
Mein Tod ist noch nicht.
Was ich bei diesem Bose-Dings ganz interessant fand,
war, dass du da weitere Erweiterungen anschließen kannst.
Das heißt, an diese Soundbar
haben sie da noch einen Subwoofer dazu angeschlossen,
per Bluetooth.
Okay.
Und du könntest hier theoretisch noch weitere Bose-
Stereo-Lautsprecher,
anständige Große mit anschließen,
per Bluetooth.
Finde ich prinzipiell ganz okay.
dann musst du nicht die Wohnung
so mit Kabeln zuhängen. Also bei mir ist es
mit den Kabeln auch schon so ein bisschen
zu viel. Ja, ist manchmal schon ein bisschen nervig, wenn man die
vor allem über Türen hinweg irgendwie legen müsste.
Ja, genau. Aber da muss ich mir noch
irgendwas Schöneres finden, weil ich möchte diesen Subwoofer
ich bin eigentlich kein Freund von diesen extra stehenden Subwoofern.
Ich finde das ist Quatsch.
Ich höre von so Leuten, die einen Subwoofer
im Stuhl haben. Im Stuhl?
Im Stuhl, damit du den Bass fühlst
statt ihn zu hören.
auch mithörst, aber vor allem mitspürst
im tieferen Magen.
Vibrierte Sitzmöbel sind mir ja nicht gesagt so ein bisschen Respekt.
Dein Sitzmöbel vibrieren, du musst es
bloß spüren in dir.
So Trompeten von Jericho-Style
muss dir schlecht werden vom Bass.
Trompeten im Arsch.
Ja, literally.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben gerade einen Punkt überschritten.
Ja, ist das jetzt ein Folgentitel?
Trompeten im Arsch.
Vibrierende Sitzmöbel.
Du hast noch ein Projekt,
wo du LOL dahinter geschrieben hast.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das auf jeden Fall bin.
Ich weiß bloß witzig, da hatte der ehemalige Folgengast Jupp,
ein GitHub-Web-Web, was ich von dem zufällig entdeckt habe,
weil ich mir letztens meine Mensa-Halbjahr geschrieben habe,
vor acht Jahren letzte Aktivität.
Die Aktivität in diesem Web-Web ist ziemlich genau zehn Monate,
bevor ich mein Studium angefangen habe, die letzte Aktivität,
hat Jupp eine Web-App für das Studentenwerk Dresden geschrieben,
wo man anscheinend schauen kann, was man so was zu essen gibt.
Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ausprobiert.
tut mir sehr leid, aber ich fand es
witzig, dass hier einfach, das Ding heißt Hungry.
Das ist ein schöner Name.
Wenn du mal so überlegst,
wo du sagst, das war, wie viele Jahre, bevor du
dein Studium begangen hast? Zehn Monate, nicht Jahre.
Achso. Ich meine, du bist
jetzt mit dem Studium fertig, jetzt fangen bestimmt
Leute an zu studieren, die sich auch
in drei Jahren dann
sich denken, ach so eine Mensa-App wäre mal praktisch
und dann irgendwann, wenn sie
halbfertig sind, über deine Mensa-App stolpern.
Ich denke, der Kilian, der hat
damals schon Mensa-Apps gebaut.
Gab es damals überhaupt schon APIs?
Gab es damals schon
Smartphones? Ich bin echt gespannt, wie so
unsere Generation im Alter
wird. Es sind dann haufenweise Leute
im Altersheim rum, die irgendwie ständig Lans
veranstalten oder was passiert denn da?
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
passieren, weil die Spiele, die
die Leute jetzt schon spielen, funktionieren nicht mehr wirklich
über LAN. Die spielen ja unsere Spiele da in Zukunft.
Die laufen ja auch jetzt noch. Über LAN?
Ja, unsere damaligen Spiele. Klar kannst du jetzt doch UT4 spielen.
Ja, gut. Aber
Spieler, die heute rauskommen, haben die meisten nicht mehr
einen dedizierten Server, den du selber hosten kannst.
Du musst dann irgendwie über
Battle.net oder was weiß ich auch nicht.
Und das wird dann, wenn wir im Altersheim sind,
nicht mehr da sein.
Ja, da brauchst du dann das neue In-Brain-Chip
WoW 2.0,
10.0,
wo du dann direkt mit deinem Hirn spielst.
Hab ich jetzt neulich nicht Werbung gesehen für irgendeinen
Anbieter, wo du dir als
Kunde einen Chip in die Hand
entgegenkriegst?
Das war heute irgendwer im Aski,
hat er das erwähnt.
Irgendwer im ASCII
hatte das erwähnt, dass irgendeine Firma
ich hab's eigentlich nicht mal, doch hab ich, aber ich hab
Notifications nicht an. Ich hatte mit dem Ton aus.
Dass irgendeine Firma ihren Mitarbeitern
Chips in die Hände implementiert hat.
Nokia, oder?
Das kann sein, irgendwas war.
Irgendwann mit Iwas.
So klassisches Biohacking-Standard-Repertoire
von wegen RFID-Chip
in der Handfläche und dann kannst du halt deine Hand
über irgendeinen Scanner swipen und deine
ID direkt mitteilen. Ich finde die Idee
geil. Ich war mal sehr kurz davor, um mir auch so ein Ding zu beschaffen,
aber ich hatte halt noch nicht den
Use Case dafür. Es gibt Leute, die nutzen sowas im Alltag,
um ihre Haustüren zu entsperren. Sobald du die
Klinke anfasst, ist sie entsperrt. Ich finde ja
die Idee her geil. Ziemlich einfach
zu klauen, vor allem wenn es ein RFID-Chip
ist, aber die Idee finde ich
immer noch super sexy. Generell so ein Biohacking-Scheiß
spricht mich so einfach an.
Ich würde da gerne alles mitmachen. Also ich möchte mich
nicht chippen lassen. Das
würde ich vielleicht mit meinem Hund oder meiner Katze machen,
aber das brauche ich nicht selber, muss ich sagen.
Vor allem so Identifikationssachen
finde ich überaus bedenklich.
Aber wir sind doch eh bald in der Dystopie angekommen,
dann wird es mandatory, das kannst du auch jetzt schon machen.
Ne, mal davon abgesehen, dass es absolut redundant ist.
Ich meine, du kannst,
wenn du einen Tesla hast,
dann wird der dadurch anlockt, dass du mit deinem Telefon
dann in die Nähe gehst. Wozu muss ich mir dann noch was in der Hand
indizieren lassen? Weil es cool ist.
Ich will, ich meine,
okay, das kommt immer zu einer Sache,
die muss schon länger... Also ich sehe keinen Vorteil gegenüber,
das nicht einfach auch über ein Telefon zu machen.
Außer, dass du das Telefon vielleicht verlierst.
Deswegen ja schon mal mit der Uhr.
Die hängt dir ja am Arm.
Ist das was Cooles, habe ich letztens festgestellt.
Dementsprechend brauchst du es eigentlich nicht mehr unter der Haut.
Ich finde das eine super dystopische Vorstellung,
dass man sich irgendwelche Chips in den Körper...
Ich will am besten meinen ganzen Körper wegschmeißen
und nur noch aus Technik bestehen.
Ja gut, okay, ich meine, dass man natürlich sein Bewusstsein
in irgendwas Unsterbliches übertragen möchte,
das wäre natürlich schon ganz nett.
Mega cool.
Aber da kommen dann andere philosophische Bedenken
mit ins Spiel.
Ja klar, da gab es so eine ganze Black Mirror Folge zu.
Dass in dieser
Zukunftsvision, wo Menschen hier
im Teddybär gesperrt waren,
dass das nicht, was meint sie,
du brauchst aus menschenrechtlichen
Menschenrechtsgründen mindestens die
Möglichkeit, fünf Emotionen zu äußern, sonst ist es
nicht, sonst ist es Quälerei
oder so. Achso.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass wenn du,
wenn man deine jetzige
Persönlichkeit in eine Maschine überträgt
und sich deine Persönlichkeit quasi nicht mehr verändert.
Dann bist du quasi nur noch so ein Abbild deiner selbst,
du kannst nichts mehr dazu lernen, kannst nichts mehr...
Und wenn du dazu guckst,
so eine Persönlichkeit ist ja auch nach einem gewissen Alter
irgendwie verbraucht.
Warum?
Du wirst mit dem Alter, verändert sich deine Persönlichkeit?
Ja, was heißt verbraucht?
Das wird ein bisschen zu tief, um das auszuholen.
Da können wir es mal bei einem Bier drüber halten.
Ja, okay, bitte.
Ich sehe das nicht ein, aber okay.
Ja, ich wäre auch sehr gerne
unsterblich gern. Ich möchte allerdings nicht
irgendwelche Chips unter der Haut haben müssen.
Das ist nur der Anfang.
Das ist schlimm genug, dass ich einen Personalausweis
mit einer Nummer mit mir rumtreiben muss.
Ja, Personalausweis, weil der Deutschland
GmbH, du...
Ach ja, ich habe noch so ein Pick.
Geht mal auf deutschland.gmbH.
Ah, das bringt mich darauf, vorhin, dass du über
htp gesprochen hast, weil die Domain von
Jakob... Jakob hatte
anscheinend, Hi Jakob, er gehört uns wahrscheinlich
nicht,
hat er vorhin im ASCII erzählt, fand ich sehr witzig,
ein HTTP-Parser
geschrieben vor ein paar Tagen
und dann hat er sehr viel Spaß gehabt,
durch die Spec zu irren,
was denn so valide Requests
sind und vor allem gerade
den Header-Parsen, ich meine, man stellt sich so
einen HTTP-Retter recht easy vor, das sind ein paar
Zeilen Text, aber
was da alles für Komplexität mit drinsteckt,
von irgendwelchen Continuations,
beziehungsweise das Geiste fand ich ja, im Header kann es auch
Kommentare reinpacken. Cool.
Aber du kannst auch mitten in dem
Paket einfach
einen neuen Header schicken und der gilt jetzt für den Rest.
Zum Beispiel hast du gemerkt, ja, die Size stimmt gar nicht.
Oder der Content-Type.
Ich ändere den einfach mal mittendrin.
Man kann mitten im Paket den HTTP-Header ändern.
Du kannst einfach plötzlich einen anderen Header sagen, stopp,
ich schicke jetzt einen anderen Header mit einem anderen Content-Type.
Was macht denn der Receiver, der vielleicht schon Speicher allogiert hat?
Der müsste halt mit umgehen.
Das ist ein nicht triviales Problem.
Aber auf die Art und Weise funktionieren ja so Sachen wie
Long-Polling, dass du irgendwie
sagst, ach hier dieses Paket, die Länge dazu
weiß ich noch nicht genau. Und dann fängst
halt an, das zu übertragen. Das lässt
sich ziemlich witzig mit bestimmten
alten
Bildstandards kombinieren.
GIF zum Beispiel hat ja kein
wohl definiertes Ende oder es ist nicht
sowas, dass du kannst ein GIF pausen, ohne dass du
es bereits zu Ende geladen hast. Da gab es
GIF-Streaming, da konntest du quasi ein
GIF anmachen und du hast es
quasi nie zu Ende geladen und der Server konnte
dir jederzeit
weitere Bilder schicken.
Dadurch konntest du quasi live so ein Ladebalken.
Ja, dann hat nicht einer drüber so ein VNC-Dings
gemacht, VNC over GIF, damit du das auch
in irgendwelche VPN-Tunnels so vorbeischieben kannst.
VNC over GIF?
Das meine ich mich jetzt
gerade zu erinnern. Da gab es irgendwie mal so ein Projekt.
Ja, VNC over GIF. Geil!
Never ending GIF-Stream.
Ist ein JavaScript geschrieben?
Natürlich ist es. Das ist nice.
Das ist überhaupt nicht nice, aber es ist geil von der Idee.
Damit haben wir noch ein Pick mehr.
Okay, haus mal bitte die Show Notes.
Ich glaube an dieser Stelle
können wir auch sagen, das wird sogar
Requirements finde ich nice.
Running VNC-Server,
Node 0.8, also es ist auch sieben
Jahre lang nichts dran gemacht worden.
2013 ist das letzte Mal, wo das angepasst wurde.
Das ist genauso alt. Und Requirements ist
mindestens Netcape 2.
Das ist ja geil.
Das ist cool. Das kann halt GIF.
Das unterstützt damit noch sehr alte
Clients. Ich wette
fast, also ich habe letztens mal versucht eine Android-App
zu schreiben und wenn du ein neues
Android-Projekt aufmachst, dann wählst du ja das
Base-API-Level aus und da sagt er dir
auch gleichzeitig direkt unter dem Dropdown,
welche Prozentzahl an Geräten du unterstützt
und du musst nicht mal das Älteste auswählen,
dass er dir 100% sagt.
Ich wette, wenn du hier Netscape 2
wie viele Clients
unterstützt du damit nicht?
Also es gibt noch die paar Leute da draußen,
die mit...
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Wie heißt der Terminal-Browser?
Links
oder E-Links oder Lynx,
die mit den Dingen unterwegs sind,
vielleicht, die kein
GIF-Support oder überhaupt Build-Support haben.
Ja, die haben aber auch sonst nichts
visuelles. Aber du wirst doch sicherlich
mit Browsern über
was war es nochmal? Netscape 2
99,959%
aller
User weltweit unterstützen können.
Aber die anderen drei Leute, die noch den anderen Browser verwenden haben, sind dann natürlich
ein bisschen angeschissen für deinen kleinen VNC-O-GIFs.
Die ist halt mega cool.
Anyway, ich glaube, wir haben es.
Das war Akronomisierbar
Folge 34.
An dieser Stelle möchte ich nochmal
der Vollständigkeit halber sagen, wenn ihr
Feedback, Anregungen, Ideen habt, wir haben ja jetzt
in den letzten Folgen mehrere Ideen aus unserem
Matrix-Channel auch aufgegriffen, vielen,
vielen lieben Dank dafür. Wenn wir in dieser Folge
Quatsch erzählt haben, dann sagt uns das
bitte auch, sagt uns das aber bitte freundlich.
Auch in unserem
Matrix-Channel, den ihr findet auf
akronomisierbar.matrix.org
Der ist auch verlinkt auf akronomisier.bar.
Der ist auf akronomisier.bar verlinkt.
Ihr könnt uns auch direkt anschreiben auf Twitter
at akronomisierbar oder
at Kilian Köhl, das ist der Kilian,
der mir hier gegenüber sitzt, oder ich bin
at hoodie-de.
Wir sind auch auf
at akronomisierbar,
ich habe das Naming-Scheme für Mastodon vergessen,
wir sind auch at chaos.social.
Wir sind auch, ich bin hoodie at chaos.social
und du bist
Kilian Kitt.
Ist das e-mail-mäßig oder war das at
Also add-key.
Ihr findet uns auf Mastodon.
Das gibt es fast,
shit.
Ab und zu denke ich auch mal dran, dass ich da irgendwie
was double poste mit dem Client, den ich habe.
Könnte ich eigentlich theoretisch über die ganze Zeit double posten.
Wenn ihr uns in real life
treffen wollt, ich werde
sein auf dem nächsten
Webmontag.
Das findet ihr auf Webmontag Dresden.
Das findet ihr auf Meetup.
Und ansonsten ist am 21.11.
das WebRTC Community Dresden
Meetup bei mir auf Arbeit.
Werd vielleicht, wenn ich Pech habe, ich reden.
Ansonsten schauen wir da
coole WebRTC Talks aus San Francisco.
Nicht vergessen,
in 56 Tagen
ist der Congress.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung
mindestens 50
Tagen ist der Congress.
Ich hab mit Mühe und Not noch ein Ticket gekriegt.
Yay, dann sind wir beide auf dem Congress.
Wir versuchen hoffentlich wieder
auf dem Sendezentrum
einen Slot zu kriegen, dass wir eine Folge akronomisierbar vom Kongress haben können.
Und wenn ihr da seid, sagt Bescheid, dann kommt ihr mit in die Folge.
Genau.
Ich glaube, bis zu fünf Leute können wir Mikros.
Genau, der Tisch ist nämlich groß und die haben sehr viele Mikros.
Also Freunde der Sendung, wenn ihr in einer gemeinsamen akronomisierbar Folge teilnehmen wollt,
ihr wisst, wir sind immer sehr interviewfreudig,
dann besucht uns doch auf dem Kongress, schreibt uns an,
wir treffen uns dort, trinken wir eine Podcast-Hörertreffen-Marte
und nehmen direkt noch eine Sonderfolge auf.
Genau, und ich glaube, damit habe ich
die gesamte Hausmeisterei
durch und wir können
jetzt mit aller Zufriedenheit
sagen, der nächste Podcast
in eurer Podcatcher beginnt in
3, 2,